Have you done a Perry Kweiman blowout review? I'm kind of I'm
kind of like butchering this content, but I think it's honestly
I'm not a huge fan of the content anyway, so I think I'm funnier
at this point. Um no, I haven't watched that, but it wasn't even
a blowout. Perry has like this habit of like he doesn't care
what you're doing when you come in. I think I saw it. Hold on.
Perry Kweiman
Can I find Can I find this? There's like a I Is it uh SN Swagger?
I think it's it's uh it's not no swagger, right? Had to clip.
This is the Sonic guy. Give me a second. I'll find it. I'll find
it. I'll find it.
Wait, what happened here? Hold on. Uh apparently there's Mau
and Aiden arguments going on. What?
Okay, hold on. I got to I'll I'll just find the clip real quick.
Yeah, this is the one with uh this is the one with Perry.
Uh by the way, this didn't happen. Perry's not like kicked out,
but Perry came in and did a bit.
Listen, there's only there's only so much Wait, is it not just
a clip? Is it not just this 1 minute 41 clip?
I've been promising Knox content for several days. Can you [__]
off? Are you wearing a Coinbase >> I'm banning you. I'm
banning >> sweater, a Coinbase
Literally banning you. Literally banning you. Listen, there's
only so many times you'd be trying to have a conversation and
Perry comes in with a totally different point in mind, right?
That he's trying to do a bit on a totally different point than
the one you're trying to move forward on.
He made two pretty rough jokes prior. Okay, hold on. Wait, also
did you link me the timestamp from the beginning? I totally I'm
totally empathetic even though I like Perry. That like there's
only so many times you can have Perry like derail before you're
like, "Yeah, I'm just leaving. Bye. Bye. Bye, Perry." Can't do
it. Can't do it.
All right, let me let me check it out. Let me Okay, guys. So,
I've been promising Knox content for several days. Can you [__]
off? Are you wearing a Coinbase >> you. I'm banning you.
I'm banning >> sweater, a Coinbase
Wait, wait, wait. He'd come in to do jokes before? Oh, Kweiman
checked out the Britney Simon content? Let's go.
Smart choice. Smart choice.
Britney is queen, okay? Literally banning you. Literally banning
you.
Nice one, Rick. Nice one, Rick. Enjoy. Enjoy never coming on
stream again.
Have fun. Okay. Yeah, you're banned. And you're banned from You
can tell Kweiman when Kweiman does the full screen camera, he's
normally thinking about like the exact thing he wants to do.
Like I think he usually wants to do like a monologue that he's
kind of planned, right? So, I'm sure he wants to do his whole
like planned Nux Taku monologue. He probably wrote some stuff
down for it. And Perry comes in and interrupts like as he's about
to start going in on it, right? I That's what I assume. When
Kweiman's full screen, he's basically always doing like uh
Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's like always doing this. He he like has
this whole monologue like if not explicitly written out, then
like written out in his head, right? He knows what he wants to
say and he's like trying to make sure he's going to do it so
it can be clipped cuz that's the whole point of doing it. And
Perry comes in and breaks his concentration. chat as well now,
Okay, also got some other jokes here. Let's check it out. He's
looking at that locket with his picture in it hanging from the
other monitor. Sometimes.
Why is Kweiman adding Nux all the time? Is it
Self-policing. I think you mean a self-policing. No, I don't
think so. So, have fun.
Have fun. And you're banned from spicy as well. So, you're basically
just like totally right. You can't talk to [__] anyone.
So, nice one, Rick. Good job. Good job. That that desperate for
attention. Are you wearing a Coinbase sweater? No, obviously
not, you
Obviously not, you [__] Unfunny loser.
Already took up. You you jumped in for two unfunny jokes and
then you join a third time to do what? To do to to say another
unfunny joke?
Listen, I
Was it really unfunny? Hold on. We'll be the judge of that. >> This is
actually a This is why I'm using L's video to have this conversation
because it's about the relationship >> the relationship
we have with the animals, non-human
What's up, Perry? What you doing? I just
I told another joke. I'll send you the picture. DMs. This is
This is what Hassan should have done. This is what This is Hassan.
This is how it would have been.
He should have got
Dude, okay. He didn't deliver. He didn't deliver. Bro, you cannot
roll into the stream and just laugh at yourself for
That's He fumbled. He fumbled hard.
From my understanding It makes it funnier for all of us, Moon
Rey Marie. It absolutely does, but it's frustrating when you're
like
Kweiman's trying to run a business, right? And he wants to do
I think videos where he can do like his nice cut intro that he's
like got a plan for and then he wants to go into his commentary
and he's like trying to make it so it's a live stream experience
that he's getting his ideas out and it's like a thing that's
supposed to be controlled, I
And Perry joins in like interrupts that and [__]
with it and it's got to be It's so funny for us, but I totally
understand why I just he just lose it. Hassan has been very loving
to Kaya and I've never known him to be neglectful to Kaya, so
I don't have any evidence though L will go over some of the other
>> actually if you don't Yeah, you're supposed to stop
doing everything, break break down into tears, uh let it ruin
your whole day and make it everyone else around you's issue like
like like how women do when their pet makes a noise. >> parts
of Hassan accusations
that I think are important, but I I want us to remember this
isn't even about Hassan. This The relationship we have with the
animals, non-human
What's up, Perry? What you doing? I just >> trying to say?
I told another joke. I'll send you the picture in DMs. This is
This is what Hassan should have done. This is what This is Hassan.
Oh, this is what Hassan should have done. This is Hassan.
>> Okay, hold on. Kweiman's laughing there. Kweiman's literally
laughing with him. Hold on. Kweiman's literally laughing with
him.
He should have Oh, no, I'm wrong. I'm totally wrong. Never mind.
That's still
This is what Hassan should have done. This is what This is Hassan.
This is how it would have been.
What was that breathing? What was the breathing laugh there then?
I thought I thought I heard Kweiman laughing under his breath,
okay? I think so. I think he was laughing at Perry >> He should
have got got a microscope out and checked on the dog, yeah? Yeah.
What do you What do you think
might have been wrong with the dog that you could find out from
a microscope, Perry? Well, that's the thing. You take it unknown
unknown. If we had the microscope, we could figure it out. >> Right.
Okay,
Hold Hold on. I need the first joke. Where is Perry coming the
first time?
I'm looking for It's back a little. Oh, Jesus. It's not that
much earlier. >> I apologize. Okay, apparently Perry Perry
is claiming to have a funny dog joke. Perry, if you've got a
funny dog joke to tell us, is that what's happening here? Yeah,
so it's um the joke made more sense before I realized that Britney
Simon is anti-Hassan.
But so just for the joke, can you pretend it's like Britney Simon
is defending Hassan? Okay.
All right, so there's a bit of a dichotomy between Britney Simon
and Nux Taku where Britney Simon
sees the dog and is like, "I I think it's good what Hassan is
doing cuz I would love to be that dog getting
On the other hand, All Rait sees the dog and is like, "This is
terrible. I should be that dog getting electrocuted. It's [__]
up that Hassan's electrocuting me instead." And I think that's
an interesting dichotomy. What do you think of that? I think
that's great observational comedy, Perry.
Thank you because it It came to me as I was really interested
Okay, hold on. Hold on.
We can all identify that this is actually what Perry's doing,
right? That he is like trying to be unfunny.
We can all identify that that he is like intentionally just being
annoying and like unfunny because he's finding that funny in
the moment. Like clearly. That By the way, that makes us that
makes me laugh way harder, but I I feel like knowing that he's
intentionally derailing your stream makes it like significantly
worse for Kweiman.
Right? Knowing that he's just trying to go on and [__]
with you for like no reason just cuz he wants he's like bored
right now and he wants to laugh at
Does he do funny stuff at other times? He does.
He can be funny. Yeah, that's the first one. We shouldn't have
gone in reverse chronological order
Perry after stream? Eh.
Maybe we'll check it out at some point. It is a bit of a slow
week, but we're all having fun. We're all enjoying ourselves.
We're having a good time. Having a great time.
Okay, we got the Red Scare stuff. I'm enjoying this.
But well, actually I'm I'm not terribly enjoying this. I kind
of want to jump over to this other [__] video.
I kind of I don't know why.
I just feel like this video is going to be funny to laugh at
and mock.
The combo on Perry's stream with Kweiman early on, but this is
where he understands why he got banned.
Why would he understand?
I didn't want Aiden here for a second, I just he messes up my
flow, you know? He messes up my flow. This must have been how
Kweiman felt when I joined his
Oh. Oh. This is how Kweiman felt when I joined his intro. I messed
up his flow, didn't I?
This is the same Oh, see, every kid is going to have It's So,
I made a video a few days ago talking >> Shut up.
>> Yeah. Banned from IC? No, I'm not.
That's like his last
This is my music, I think. Yeah, that's my music.
Some dude Some dude just joined named the Austrian painter. I
don't know if that guy's going to be safe.
But you know what but I you know
It was like a funny convo.
I get it was funny but I have a boundary that I set and
What did Perry What did Perry do to Aiden? Did Perry like steal
some some [__] from Did he not steal? Did he like
record Aiden? A convo? Did he Is he leaking DMs? What's going
on here? Consistent donor in Chad's chat, you have to be referring
to somebody else. You can't possibly be referring to Perry. Perry
is not a consistent donor in Chad's chat. There's a 0% chance
of that. Oh, the Austrian painter guy is a consistent Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Sorry, I I totally misunderstood you, Cam.
It's like, dude, Perry Perry's only source of income was Paragon.
So, all right.
we are continuing. All right, I I'll be honest with you guys.
I just want to watch Oh, wait. Yeah, you're right. Hold on, we
got to do the
I want to watch this video but we got to do the Mero Aiden beef
first. What the [__] was that? Why was there Mero
Aiden beef? [__] Dude, this clip right here, Mero
responds to call allegations. The call allegations.
You would think after Aiden called me like three times and I
didn't pick up. No, I'm not going to call into a stream to talk
about it.
I've talked about it on stream like twice at this point. I don't
Talk about what? Is this the 17-year-old thing? There's no way
that Aiden wants to talk about it again, is there?
I feel like after after Mero like totally uh
a cheeto, doesn't Aiden like have Don't care to go on to Aiden's
stream and explain something that's like 2 years
uh that I have like a vague recollection of. So, no. Do it again?
Uh I was with the guy. I made a video on him and before I uploaded
the video, I wanted to [__] with him.
Cuz I thought it was funny to uh troll him cuz he was like super
off
Uh and I thought he was like a disgusting freak. So, I thought
it was funny to [__] with him. So, I went into his
server and [__] with him. That's like That's it.
I don't really know what else there is to say about the call.
That's all That's all it was.
I don't really know how the guy in the video cuz I By the time
I got around to like watching clips, he had already taken it
down. The video's I think up
I don't know how the guy in the video tries to spin the call
or what he tries to say.
something about toys or me saying play with toys or whatever.
I'm pretty sure I was just referencing like a meme at the time.
Some like JSS
or JCS channel
uploaded a thumbnail that I thought was funny that I was just
referencing. Questionable call with Mero and a 15-year-old. Well,
that's not what he's talking about now. >> like he played
with toys or something. I don't know what the specific allegation
is supposed to be. He was Like yeah, I was just [__]
with the guy. I don't really know what else there is to explain.
I don't feel the need to like make an official response to this
and call into streams to discuss this or litigate this. I don't
really give a [__] It's like 2 years old at this
point. I just don't care.
Mero don't give a [__] Okay.
And then hold on, we've got the
got the Aiden response.
Aiden being very hard >> allegation is supposed to be.
He was
Like yeah,
I was just with the guy. Go. There's no specific allegation.
There's something that looks bad that I would love some elaboration
on but you're too much of a to call in and talk about it.
I Nobody's even making an Bro, everybody's hurting for content
so badly. People are going Listen, this is what happens, okay?
When when people are starving,
cannibalism becomes a thing, all right? These guys are friends.
There's a bunch of friends. This could be Perry's friends with
Queenman and there's a content drought and it's causing major
content food shortages and people are starting to eat each other,
all right? We stocked up for the winter, all right? We stocked
up for the winter. We're all But holy [__]
These guys are going hard at each other.
Oh, don't worry. So, Aiden's about to tell him that he should
leave commentary or something?
There's 200 hours of Kaya content. That's true. We could do infinite
Kaya content. I actually have We could go to all of the clips
from this stream where Hassan was watching walking Kaya. We can
find all of the all of the clips about the dog.
Listen, this is the clip This is the clip No, sorry, sorry. He's
walking fish here. This is the tail grabbing stream.
Yes, the tail grabbing stream.
We could go look at all the clips from this stream and see if
there's anything. You just do infinite Hassan dog abuse
That is a That is an an endless well I forgot about.
All right, back to this Aiden clip. There is no specific allegation.
There's something that looks bad that I would love some elaboration
on but you're too much of a fat to call in and talk about it.
Very rude. >> Nobody's even making an allegation yet. I
just want to figure out what the [__] is going on
and the fact that like you're completely unwilling to like sit
and answer questions about it is just like completely absurd
to me.
Okay. You know, be my guest if you don't want to call in. Who
is Who is Aiden to call out Mero, okay? Mero lived his life.
Mero is actually interesting. The reason why Aiden can sit on
his uh on his throne of lies here and dictate morality to Mero
is because Aiden never interacts with other human beings in any
sort of any way other than like a robotically, okay? Aiden, how
about you live a life before you call out Mero?
All right? Live a life. Experience anything other than being
groomed as a child in the commentary community, okay?
And I'm not making fun of you for that. That's genuinely that
hurts me. >> But quit commentary while you're at it, okay?
Quit Do like anime reviews or some [__] because you
have no business criticizing others and scrutinizing others when
you're like this
I don't know what the specific
Well, Jesus. What's being swept for here? I have no idea. I don't
know. Somebody said it's a call with a 15-year-old
and I'm just I'm just beaming about Mero living a good life,
okay? He's just lived He's just lived his life dangerously.
And instead of loving the content, okay? Instead of loving the
fact that he can provide you content, you want to hate this guy?
You want to tell him to leave commentary? How was Aiden groomed?
I have no idea. I just say the thing that I've heard before.
Honestly, probably not groomed. Probably not groomed by like
a gay older man. Gay older black man?
Probably not groomed but I've heard it so many times that I just
repeat it. He knows I'm joking.
He knows it's a joke.
What are we
Tommy C groomed him? I don't think so.
What are we looking for? There's There's
What is this?
So, I've heard that there are other clips with like the dog here
where things get like kind of out of control. Jesus Christ.
The last thing any given toddler sees before their doom befalls
them is this
ferocious like panting beast.
I'm I'm just hearing in my head the screams of like a thousand
babies, okay?
Just a thousand babies cried out and were silenced all at once.
Basketball phased up. Basketball phased
Maybe I'd be able to dunk if I had my oofies or my oozies, my
elevator shoes, my platform shoes, you know?
Dog's definitely walking over to some other dogs and he's not
paying >> promo code daddy dick.
Your Your dog is walking away from you, sir. Sir, your dog Your
dog Your pitbull is about to chase this guy down. Hassan, what
are you doing? >> Look at this little thing. What's up,
little nugget?
Chill. Chill.
Hey, no.
Dude, he only just realized his dog is like chasing somebody
and barking at
Uh Jesus.
Chat. My crazy I'm crazy Pretty sure he was like actually going
after this guy.
And Hassan just doesn't give a [__] He starts like
barking.
Dude, you don't see the guy break into a But Jesus.
Fish in his prong collar? Yeah, but the I don't know if the prong
collar's like Oh, man.
Listen, no act against pitbulls uncalled for, okay?
48 minutes.
Where's the actual one here? This is uh 5 minutes. Where's the
actual 51 minutes? So, somewhere around 51 minutes, I think.
But like uh 48 minutes was right there. So, this is right after
he had been chasing that guy.
So, we're looking for between 48 minutes and 51 minutes for a
clip. Here's 53. Here's another one that is right before he does
the tail pull. Wait, before or after?
Okay, it's just him playing basketball.
47 minutes. Dude, how do we not have this bot somewhere?
Can someone explain that to me? Oh, this thing IS A BEAST.
JESUS CHRIST.
I'm still I'm still just looking. Oh, there is nothing There
is nothing else with the dog.
Is that 48 minutes where he like chases those people?
And you never see him wrangle the dog at
So, this is 51 minutes. This is the bad one. Oh, we can load
more clips. Hold We'll load more clips.
Oh, we could keep loading clips. Oh, we're getting so many clips.
Come on. 46? No.
We need like 48 49
We're looking. Okay. Hold on. Is there a clips tab or something?
Clips.
I know it'll get me off of the stream, though. So, I don't want
to do that.
Dog park stream 54.
I realize this seems like it's not fruitful, guys, but if we
find the right clip, okay, it will be immediately fruitful. We're
just looking for Oh, that's all the
Find VOD for this stream. No VODs for this stream. Dude. This
is May 30th, 2019.
Dude, someone's got this VOD somewhere. Where is this VOD? It's
somewhere out
And we need it. We need it to judge the tail pulling clip. [__]
am I listening to? I don't know. Some crazy music in the background.
F5 F5 F5. Why are you saying F5? Refresh
The no streams.
There are stream.
Can you There are stream. There are
Maxsmith, can you just message me with like full sentences on
Discord or
Uh I have no music taste, also. I don't care. This is literally
a generated playlist. I literally don't care. I'm not listening
to music at a level where I can like really audibly comprehend
it.
If you guys care about it,
you guys care about it, you can send me music if you want. I
just don't give a [__] It's literally just so that
there's not uh like dead air in the background so that you could
tell like I'm still here. This [__] hasn't died.
He gave a dog to a Muslim man. Find out what happened next. Number
three will shock you. Okay. You saw no clips.
Yeah, I kept hitting like the refresh thing and then
after a little while, it says there are no more clips here.
Right? We went to the very top of this and this like out of clips.
There's no more clips to be loaded from this stream. Workum as
well? Yeah, I looked at all of them. I looked through all of
them. I refreshed all of them. I don't Maximus, please just message
me on Discord if you want to.
Oh, wait wait wait wait. I see what you're saying. Okay. So,
we don't have anything. It's 48 It's the dog chasing and then
he eventually grabs the dog's
So, it's literally we just don't have this this gap of like 48
minutes to 51 minutes. We have this one and this one's not even
viewed, okay? This one fish is about to go chase some dude down,
right? Fish is about to go chase some dude down and then Hassan's
grabbing him by the tail. So, we need this this 3-minute section
here of What happened with fish? What happened with him grabbing
the tail?
What is going on? We need to figure it
This is This exists somewhere. I guarantee you there's some dude
who has like this VOD archived somewhere in the
It exists.
We just need to find it, okay?
All right. I think without further ado
it might be time to hop onto this video.
What do we got left for time on the stream? I think we got a
decent amount of time left, right? we're good. We're good. We're
good?
Hour 28? Yeah, we can try it. We can try it. We can make it work.
Well, we probably can't make it work, but check YouTube with
the date. I have May 30th, 2019. I cannot find it.
Uh it's May 30th, 2019. Here is the VOD page, okay? Or it I'll
put it in the chat. You guys can take a look, but it is nowhere.
It is ghosted. It's not out there on YouTube. It's not out there
anywhere I can find.
And I would like to. Anyway,
listen, guys.
I spent 1 week watching The Young Turks at HasanAbi uncle, okay?
Based.
Based farming? We love to see it.
It gave me more brain worms than RFK Jr.
More brain worms than RFK Jr. No way.
national level, we have lost our
It does not exist. >> So, I got really bad news for you.
None of your representatives represent you. They represent the
people who pay them. Yes, the Republicans are dirty and corrupt
as it gets, but so are the Democrats. How about the guy who promised
us change?
Has that working out for us? He said, "I'm going to change That
Obama guy sucks. Nothing changed. >> the game. Really?
What have you done At HasanAbi uncle, yes. >> going to
change the game. No, no, no. He has no intention of changing
a damn thing. So, you're waiting for a hero? WELL, WE ALREADY
HAD A HERO WHO PROMISED us overwhelming change and then gave
us nothing. Now, the next guy that comes and puts that sign up
that's He gave us nothing. He gave us nothing, MAN. COME ON.
SAYS CHANGE. >> I love THIS CHANGE GUY. HE'S SO COOL. >> NO,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BELIEVE him because nine out of 10 No, 99
out of 10 times he's a liar.
He 99
out of 10. He's got money to lie to you. You cannot rely on the
federal government. They're the bad guys. They're not listening.
You think we're having a debate IN THIS COUNTRY? WAIT, I DIDN'T
even see the text. We're We're just watching cuz this guy did
such a bad job on that Hassan video. Just like points that have
no connection to the relevant like core thesis of the segment,
right? All over the place. It's falling apart everywhere. Conduit
really found the [__] in his armor. Gentle whale,
why did you switch your name to Gentle whale?
Out of nowhere. You're not G whale, you're Gentle whale. This
is This is off-putting. Oh, but it's a You still have your old
account. No, you don't. What the hell?
It's a different account. Yeah, I got a The Young Turks.
The Young >> Well, uh before I never entertained
September. Okay, I'm just going to let
I'm just going to let them go off and do their thing. I'm going
to go to the
And I will be right back, okay? I'm going to go to the bathroom.
Um I'm also probably going to get some water. I'm a little low.
So, I'll be right
Why did I see a meme today about someone being in love with user
Gentle whale? What? I don't know. And the idea that uh and 9/11
was anything but what the government said. >> Right. I'm
not running around saying 9/11 was an inside job. But I'm not
I don't know.
What are we doing here? At some point I want to just make a video
where I rank Adam Sandler movies or something. But then someone
says something like
>> And I just few things off the bat. One, the response
I've gotten is absolutely incredible. I expected to get maybe
50 views on my first Hassan vid and the idea that not only over
100,000 people have watched this, but that they actually liked
it and wanted more is insane to me. Thank you so much. Two, I
started a Patreon. Right now, I'm still new and learning, so
I can't promise a whole lot, but this would help me focus more
of my time on these videos and improve the quality. No obligation.
I'm still going to try to make more videos either way. Three,
how do I feel about the CEO of Twitch being called in front of
Congress? Honestly, not great. The Republican majority in Congress
has taken the legitimate issue of anti-Semitism on Twitch and
YouTube and twisted it into a crusade against their own enemies.
If they manage to get Hassan banned that way, it won't be a victory.
To borrow an adjective, using the brittle power of authority
to force Twitch's hand without any kind of cultural shift or
structural change beyond it means that once their authority is
broken, there's nothing holding back a reversion to where we
started. The way I see it, the only way through that has a lasting
impact is Dan Clancy banning Hassan himself.
Hold on. Hold on.
Same guy as that video. Dude. All right.
I wasn't here as this guy like monologued. Um yeah, 100,000 views
for that video. That video was like so poorly put together. Like
I I can't stress enough how often we watched it and he'll just
like go off He'll like put some [__] in there for
a tangent that has nothing to do with the current topic. Like
repeatedly.
It's kind of It's It's baffling to watch.
That like people
Yeah, I I assume it was just it's a anti-Hassan video that Dan
linked on his
That That seems to be all that it takes. >> self. Now,
The Young Turks will tell you Okay, also he says that the only
way for Twitch to change is for Dan Clancy to ban Hassan himself.
Okay. Wow. >> repeatedly, incessantly, that they operate
on principles of honesty and integrity. But then you'll hear
something like I don't know. And you have to wonder, what's going
on? They've got over 6 million YouTube subscribers. They've been
operating on YouTube near enough since the site was founded when
Cenk Uygur started posting videos and streaming in 2005.
They've expanded a number of shows under their umbrella, and
they've been a hot spot for a lot of well-known progressive and
leftist journalists like Emma Vigeland, now with The Majority
Report. >> Who cares if Hezbollah has money? They're a
political party in a different country. I mean, you can call
them a terrorist organization. They're a resistance organization
towards Israel, and I'm sure if I were to parse through the views
of this resistance group, that I would find many of their views
distasteful. Ryan Grim, owner of Trapsite News, Hamman I just
Hold on. I This is what he does all of the time, right? He'll
very regularly put a clip on and he will never ever say what
his problem with the clip is. He will just let the play the clip
play and like sit back smugly smiling being like, "Got him. Got
him. Got him. She said she doesn't know if Hamas is like a ter
She said it's a resistance group. Got him." It's Okay, uh you
want to Do you want to make a point? Do you want to make some
assertion good bad? You agree disagree? I mean we all know he
>> the number of shows under their umbrella and they've
been a hot spot for a lot of well-known progressive and leftist
journalists like Emma Vigeland now with the majority report.
>> Who cares if Hezbollah has money? They're political
party in a different country. I mean you can call them a terrorist
organization. They're a resistance organization towards Israel
and I'm sure if I were to parse through the views of this They're
a political party that's a part of the like entire administration
of Gaza. There is they have a military wing that is largely like
terrorist driven. They have obviously horrible values, but they
are the group that like protects those people. There's like something
to be said for having authority there. They just agreed to peace.
And a lot of people would say, "Oh, there could never be peace
without them being like totally eviscerated, totally
I was all wrong. >> resistance group that I would find
many of their views distasteful. >> Ryan Grim Wait, hold
on. Wait, what?
Hold on. This is another one of those things. It just happened
again, didn't it? Hezbollah has explicitly called for gay people
to be killed.
She said Hezbollah. They've been a hot spot for a lot of well-known
progressive and leftist Oh, I mean the same thing would apply
in either case, right? Um sorry, I I misunderstood or I mis-
I misheard. Yes, Hezbollah is also a political party. They have
a political like structure, right? I think that's kind of fallen
apart after Israel killed their leadership. >> journalists
like Emma Vigeland now with the majority report. >> Who
cares if Hezbollah has money? They're a political party in a
different country. I mean you can call them a terrorist organization.
They're a resistance organization towards
Oh, see I
I missed it and then I just looked at the October 7th thing and
launching rockets and I I just lost my mind. >> Israel
and I'm sure if I were to parse through the views of this resistance
group that I would find many of their views distasteful. >> Ryan
Grim owner of dropsite news This is your savage brutal bunch
of savage brutal rapists. >> say evidence cuz then I'll
say, "Well, what evidence do we have?" According to the UN, they
don't actually have any evidence that participated. >> Are
we then of the opinion that like maybe a couple
It's extremely likely that without Comey's double last intervention,
Comey's double last intervention in the 2016 campaign, Trump
doesn't win. You would think there'd be some
They don't actually have any evidence that participated. >> Are
we then of the opinion that like maybe a couple to related violence
happened and then Israel What? Hold on. I'll I'll let it play
and then I'm going to go back and try to figure out what the
point of this is. is largely fabricating the claim. >> Well,
I mean we we know for certain that much of it is fabricated.
>> Crystal Ball's husband, Jimmy Dore Okay, much of it
is fabricated.
All right, so we'll look at these logs
So, Grim says that you So, I assume
Sorry, I assume one took over that Grim's point is, "Why are
you trying to indict James Comey?"
September 24th, 2025,
Trump doesn't win without Comey's intervention.
Why are you try I I would assume that you would like to show
gratitude towards the person who helped you win, who made sure
you win?
That's the point here, right?
Uh and then September 27th, 2015
Did Clinton set up private email to make it harder for Congress
and the media access it? That never crossed my mind, says Clinton.
So, I quote.
I'm just going to try to figure out what point is being made
here.
Right? If there's any point being made. The Democratic straw
man creation of fictional GOP racist extremist is now leading
in the polls. Hillary Clinton couldn't be happier.
Uh this is talking about Hillary cheering for cheering for Trump,
I assume in the primaries that she feels like he's a beatable
candidate. We know that Democrats felt like pretty comfortable
about Trump being their opponent, so I don't understand the point.
I've no idea what Grim is saying. I just told you what he's saying.
Open your ears, okay? Clean your [__] ears out. I
just told you exactly what he means. How is it It's not confusing,
okay? All right. Did you know that Bill Clinton linked up with
an infamous white supremacist in his first bid for
New York Times, Hillary Clinton would have squeezed Iran and
potentially blown up the nuke talks.
Uh Clinton refusing So, we searched Clinton in Ryan Grim's tweets.
I Did he Didn't he do this with his son, too? Wasn't he like,
"Oh, there's a lot of criticism for the Clintons. I don't like
that."
Does this guy just look for Is he like, "Oh, if criticizing the
Clintons is bad?" Is that all we're looking for? Sorry, I actually
I actually want to like untangle this and figure out what this
guy's trying to say cuz I would love to know how he got 100,000
views on that video from before or 20,000 views on this one.
So, it's just him It's It's Ryan Grim saying bad things about
Hillary Clinton in 2016, right?
Yeah, yeah, but it's not confusing on Ryan Grim's part. It's
confusing on the author's part. The author of this video is making
I don't know what point. The Cain pick neatly eases the way for
Clinton's best friend Terry McAuliffe to McAuliffe to wind up
a senator, too. I wonder what choice he lobbied for.
After months of deliberation, the Clinton campaign settles on
doing the lame boring thing everybody knew they would do a year
ago. Sad. So, he's criticizing Hillary Clinton.
Um is it Is the implication that he wants Trump to win because
he's criticizing Hillary Clinton, I guess. Look, this guy helped
Trump win by saying Clinton sucks in some ways.
Uh one took over. You're saying you had no idea what Grim is
saying. See? Look at your message from before. Very obvious what
Ryan Grim is saying. Maybe you should type coherent sentences,
you know? Uh the concept is just You're on the left, but you
dare to criticize the Democrats, I think.
Yeah. Uh yeah, that is what it is. It's just like, "Oh, you criticized
Hillary while Trump is running." I guess.
Uh by the way, does anyone remember what the prevailing sentiment
was at this
The prevailing sentiment was Hillary landslide, 400 electoral
votes, 99 to 1, 99% to 1% chance. That was the prevailing opinion.
A lot of people were perfectly comfortable criticizing Hillary
Clinton because they assumed she had no way to lose.
This is a totally like um
It's like a totally vapid point. There's no point here. He literally
just went to Ryan Grim's Twitter and searched >> old sexually
related violence happened. Okay, now we got another page. Reporter
who broke Kavanaugh story explains how accuser's account got
delayed. Reporter Ryan Grim who broke the news, Christine Blasey
Ford goes public with allegation that Brett Kavanaugh tried to
her in high school. Privacy being chipped away, our calculation
changed. These are all the ills that I was trying to avoid, she
said, explaining her decision to come forward. Now I feel like
my civic responsibilities outweighing my anguish and terror about
retaliation. Kavanaugh's confirmation.
Why suffer through the annihilation if it's not going to matter,
she said. I have no [__] idea what this says. Reporter
who broke Kavanaugh story explains how accuser's account got
So, he he did something that delayed the Christine Blasey Ford
news? happened and then Israel is largely fabricating the claim.
Well, I mean we we know Surely there will be some commentary
to explain. Maybe. >> for certain that much of it is fabricated.
Crystal Ball's husband, Jimmy Dore, Shaun King, Nina Turner,
Russian mouthpiece Dave Rubin, and Cenk Uygur's nephew.
are you going to do, bro?
Love you, one took over.
Love you. I I also love that you can give and not take it, but
that's fine. >> credit, their operation is a lot more
I don't have to be nice to this guy. This guy. No, I don't actually.
I like this guy, but um Jerry just said be nice to this guy.
You believe that? >> channel news like that a regular stream.
Though that isn't exactly a high bar. You'll get a specific piece
of news and a basic overview of the facts before Cenk and his
co-host Ana Kasparian get into their own perspectives, basically
acting as anchor and pundit. It seems like they really vie for
legitimacy. I don't know. >> And I do want to know. So,
I watched one week of streams and I'm going to tell you what
I learned. And since their main show is only a couple of hours
long, hopefully this will be a bit more easy going than my last
two subjects. One last thing, I promise this won't be a series
exclusively about left-leaning media. It's not like Asmongold
is actively streaming right now, anyway.
We begin the day after Charlie Kirk's murder while the killer
and their ideology still haven't been identified. >> Yeah,
so this is super strange. They very rarely go on a rooftop, plan
it out
>> Of course, looking back knowing what we do now, it's
easy to say that someone's obviously wrong. But we're not going
to have that problem. No, none of this looks like an amateur.
If they catch him and we find out a rational explanation,
I mean it didn't look like a How would you put it? It didn't
look like
like a rank amateur. It didn't look like the Philadelphia guy
that Sorry, the Pennsylvania guy. It looked very different from
that. >> Great, that's awesome. If they don't catch him,
>> we will pull out the world map and speculate wildly.
>> You're telling me one shot makes a clean getaway and
he wasn't a professional? >> Professional assassins in
the vein Cenk is talking about don't actually exist, especially
ones that would target someone high profile in a western
Uh I feel like there's no way that's true, right?
I feel like there's absolutely no way that contract killers don't
exist.
I understand that like contract killers like the movies don't
necessarily But there have to be people who are
There's just There's like a market demand. There would be a market
demand.
I know for a fact that like gangs do this. Like gangs do this,
but they Gangs know that if they go and try to kill president,
they're going to get [__] up, right?
So, they go and they do they'll they'll like kill civilians,
like low-profile civilians for you.
But they definitely don't go and like try to kill presidents
or politicians because that's like how you That's how you get
your whole operation seized and [__] destroyed. This
investigation so far has been abysmal. That also, of course,
furthers some conspiratorial >> trust our government at
all anymore. That's weird. That's also weird. We couldn't find
any trace of him except this rifle and the casings and it says
transgender and antifa. Then the New York Times says, "Oh, by
the way, that might not be true at all." What the F is going
on here? Cash Patel, yeah, sure, he's a clown. He also weirdly
took off the lead FBI person in Salt Lake City just a little
while back. That's super weird. Cash Patel is uniquely unqualified
to run the FBI and like
Yeah, most of the federal government since January 20th, the
FBI has been purged of anyone who has shown even a trace of antipathy
towards Trump. But conspiracies like what Cenk is not so subtly
alluding to requires way too many people at all levels, including
state and local, to be involved and by that point it's impossible
to actually pull off. What we I mean, I tend to agree with most
of these points.
The funny thing is is
we still get like a lot of conspiracy posting. I tend to think
that like conspiracies within the FBI might start becoming like
possible.
I just don't think that the Tyler Robinson shooting is one of
those things. I think I think that would require way too much
coordination. Not >> What I witnessed at the time was not
a potential cover-up. It was a thousand different people, mostly
outside the government, trying to get ahead of whatever the truth
turned out to be. This isn't the 1960s. You're not going to be
able to go, "Oh, yeah, there was a magic bullet. Yeah, a bunch
of senators looked into it." It's not even 9/11. "Oh, yeah, a
bunch of senators looked into it." >> Oh, goody, we're
doing JFK conspiracies, too. And then we get our first ad break
for TYT sponsors, PrizePicks and Chapter. More on them later.
We come back to more conspiracy, maybe? >> Remember, there's
so many different countries that would love to sow division and
hatred in this country. I mean, I wrote on social media today
they should double Trump's Secret Service.
That's I mean, that is true. That like if I was concerned about
people influencers for
for anything, I I think the PBD one, if you're going to be conspiracy
brain, that's the one I would like, right? Just like Iran, China,
Russia, any of these countries could try to like get somebody
who's not like a politician, who is like a private citizen, to
stir division within the country. I think that's like a possibility.
If you hit Trump, there's going to be an uncontrollable rage
in this country.
Not not that I thought this was that. I just like there's no
reason.
Let's just be real. No professional, nobody who's trying to get
away with it would try to pull off this assassination in broad
daylight, uh with like this thing being live streamed or being
recorded by like a thousand, 10,000 phones, right? Like that's
the element of this that makes it totally amateurish or makes
it makes you think it's not anybody with like an organized
cohesive plan to get away.
They almost got away cuz the FBI is incompetent, but >> Not
true. It's not really worth explaining that doubling Trump's
Secret Service doesn't just equal twice as protected, but we've
now extrapolated from Charlie Kirk getting shot in Utah that
someone is going to take a shot at Trump on the other side of
the country. And now we begin the whitewashing of Charlie Kirk
and the both siding of political violence. Watch the Republicans
say, "Oh, Charlie would have wanted you to limit freedom of speech."
No, I I don't think he would have. >> Just want to note
that political violence has unfortunately harmed people on both
sides of the political aisle. The rhetoric used on both sides
of the political aisle can get fiery. To pretend like that only
exists on the left is a bit ridiculous. Anna has an interesting
interpretation of Trump's >> Trump kind of ebbs and flows.
You'll hear him say things that I believe as president of the
United States is incredibly responsible at a time when a leader
should be trying to cool tensions. This morning Trump kind of
changed his tone in a private message to CNBC's Joe Kernen. Is
it worth noting that a CNBC financial news host read a note that
was contradicted by the president himself not long after anyway?
>> It would be nice to hear that message directly from
the president's mouth. I thought not. >> Actually, later
today, Trump changed his tone yet again. You know, Charlie Kirk
was not someone who was on the far, far right, okay? In fact,
he had a pretty significant group of haters who were on the right
of him. That's not evidence
Yeah, this uh that he isn't far right. That just means that there
are people who don't have a problem being more direct about it.
The difference between saying I'm sorry, if I see a black pilot,
I'm going to be like, "Boy, I hope he's qualified." And Hassan,
Destiny, hey idiots, this Zionist-backed Republican government,
they're waiting, they're begging for the opportunity, for a reason,
to wipe the far left off the map because the leftists protest
Israel. Instead like your uncle of recognizing >> Wait,
no, that example, he agrees with you. Which is, you know, inspiring
some public figures on the right to declare that we're at war,
that they're at war with the left. >> Interesting slip
there. I don't The rhetoric I'm hearing is really scary. So the
answer to that is it's it's the left's fault. It's the right's
fault. I should be obvious to all of us, but I don't think it's
even close to obvious. Cenk reads a viewer comment about George
W. Bush. But the one thing I'll always give him credit for is
that he united us after 9/11. You know, I wanted to reflexively
disagree with this one because my memories of the Bush era are
somewhat blurry at this point. But um >> Our nation is
waging a war on a radical network of terrorists, not on a religion
and not on a civilization. One of the deepest commitments of
America
is tolerance. No one should be unfairly judged by appearance
or ethnic background or religious faith. What is happening in
the world that I missed the calls for unity from George W. Bush?
Uh there are some isms that occasionally pop up. One is isolationism
Bro, we uh I'm telling you, listen. Maybe we should just all
be on board. Maybe the bugs won't be so bad, okay? If it if this
is what it takes for like the world to function and for the economy
to work is we just got to eat a couple bugs. Maybe the bugs aren't
so bad. isolationism
and its evil twin protectionism and its evil triplet nativism.
There was an American first policy that said, "Who cares what
happens in Europe?" What happened in Europe mattered because
of World War II. There was Smoot-Hawley, which is part of an
economic policy which basically said we don't want trade. An
immigration policy that I think during this period argued we
had too many and too many Italians, therefore we should have
no immigrants. I'm a little concerned that we may be going through
the same period. >> Every single prominent left-winger,
and I mean prominent left-winger with a significant following,
has not called for continued violence against the >> So you
won't mind if I just grab this clip in case you obviously foreshadowing.
The pearl clutching from Hold on, I need to I mean prominent
left-winger with a significant following has not called for continued
violence against the right. >> So you won't mind if I just
grab this clip in case you obviously foreshadowing. The pearl
clutching from the right is really bothering me considering the
record of their calls for violence or their mocking of left-wing
figures. Calling out a congressman's hypocrisy isn't nothing,
but doesn't hold a lot of weight when it's put on equal footing
with TikToker leftism is based 4927 who only has 10 followers.
I didn't see any prominent figures on the left or Democrats saying
anything awful. It was smaller accounts or just randos. But whenever
I ran into one of them, like they're joking around about his
neck wound. I'm like, "Oh, Jesus Christ, what's wrong with you
>> I did not know that Charlie Kirk said this about Anna.
>> He essentially said that since I don't have children,
I don't care about the future of this country. Good lord. >> I haven't
been able to like kind of shake it off. What I appreciated about
Wait, what? Why would she say that?
That really haunts me to this day. >> Charlie Kirk was
that he provided a platform for people who disagreed with him.
People who don't understand the value of that really frustrate
me because you're not thinking strategically and you don't really
care about winning. Yeah, I've been banned by mainstream media
and so a lot of the right-wing shows have been more open-minded
about having me on than MSNBC or CNN. >> That might be
worth interrogating as to why, you know? I can't believe that
they're asking Anna on and she's been doing amazing job and she's
going to be on CNN tonight at 10:00. But in my experience, ONLY
A CERTAIN SET OF IDEAS ARE ALLOWED. IF YOU GO OUTSIDE THE GARDEN,
that's it, you're out. >> Well, that makes it sound more
like a you problem then, chief. There are some who are attempting
to lower the
Dude, what what? Cenk, yeah, it's just it's literally just Cenk.
They just don't like Cenk.
Cenk literally like talks CNN all the time. He literally mocks
all of the anchors. It's not even the bleeps. The bleeps aren't
outside the lines. They love they love radical people going on
CNN. They get clips, they get all the [__] they want.
Right? It's that Cenk goes and he's like unhinged to them. He's
like CNN's a total piece of [__] All these anchors
get like $50,000 a night to go and go and feed like the the masses
whatever narrative, right? He's like constantly [__]
on them. Anna doesn't do that. Anna just says, "You know, I don't
know if 9/11 was an inside job." That's the exact kind of person
they want on CNN. One of those individuals is conservative commentator
Eric Erickson. There is Marxist ideology. They don't want you
to know they're lying, they don't want you to believe they're
lying, they don't want to act like they're lying. What they're
doing is they're using different words to then get you to embrace
their reality. It's very pernicious. It's why you do have to
insist men or men and women or women. Here Cenk misunderstands
how Grok works. Um so I've told you guys before, I like Grok.
I love that there's an AI out there that scours 60,000 or 100,000
videos, whatever we have online. >> "Also, I'm extremely
surprised he likes the AI propaganda child of Elon Musk." Like
I figured someone on YouTube would prefer Gemini. The next story
they cover is the murder
Uh Grok's convenient because a lot of people already have Twitter
installed. And it works fairly well. And like at the points where
it is just propaganda, it's like the only way to use AI is to
like get the sources, read the sources, or use it to search for
things, right? But you don't use it to like give you straight-up
opinions most of the time. I'll do it when I'm like when I'm
on a topic that I don't know. Uh I'll do it as like, "Oh, I think
this is this seems like reasonable."
But like if I don't know. I started using um
Oh, I started using Perplexity to find like politics content
for stream and Perplexity's pretty based for that. Perplexity's
pretty good, man. Like it'll find me YouTube videos. I'll be
like, "Hey, what's the latest story happening here? Can you find
me like some some new stories on it?" And then I'll just read
those new stories on
I don't know. I like it. I think it's pretty good.
I think Grok would probably be pretty
I think. Like I'm yeah. The Google the search AI is not the best
all the time from what I've seen. I don't love the search AI
as much. early Ukrainian refugee by a schizophrenic man on a
train. Let's see where TYT's audience is at with it. Well, I'm
a little worried about it. Wow, yes is winning dramatically.
No, I don't agree with that at all. >> Good, you shouldn't.
No, wait, they're actually talking about the ACLU. I'd like to
know, what does the ACLU have to say about his freedom?
No, I only use it sorry, I only use it to like get the story
and like read through and figure out what's going on when I have
been like out of the loop.
Gentle will. I don't um
Like obviously I just I watch the show.
We watch the show. We read it, okay?
It just collects things for me so I don't have to go to a bunch
of different >> Um today The best I could find that justifies
this critique is a Supreme Court case back in the 70s that was
specifically about people who are not dangerous and not mentally
unwell being institutionalized anyway. The kind of regulation
Genk explicitly supports here. I am for involuntarily institutionalizing
some people. We had the bad old days where their standards for
institutionalizing people were terrible and the places they sent
them were even worse. Now Anna tries to put a class spin on the
stabbing. Places where the elite, if you will, don't have to
worry about using if they need to go to and from work. Rich people
also take the train. Nothing helps feed into the desires of neoliberals
who do what who do not want to spend any resources on public
services than this ideology that just essentially says, "Oh,
no. We're doing it for freedom." This is gobbledygook. Neoliberal
here doesn't mean anything. If they want to say Bill Clinton
cut mental health programs the same way Reagan did, there was
reduced expansion in his health care bills, but overall his administration
sought increased funding. Who's neoliberal after that? Obama?
I mean, Biden increased funding with the Bipartisan Safer Communities
Act of 2022. They don't want to spend tax revenue The slow erosion
of institutions that can manage and treat the mentally ill has
been going on for decades due to government budget cuts and ideological
opposition by people who think the mentally ill just need more
Jesus. Also, why is this a story you're covering at all? What
happened here is a tragic failure of multiple systems to protect
Wait, what? Why why is the North Carolina murder of the Ukrainian
woman something they're
That's Listen, he's he's making okay points on some of the stuff
that would just be more research-based like correcting maybe
some of the points, but
and then I don't understand how he goes here. Oh, why are you
even covering this at all? I don't know cuz it's a massive news
story that everybody's talking about and we run a news program
where people want to hear about like the actual thing that's
trending. need more Jesus. Also, why is this a story you're covering
at all? What happened here is a tragic failure of multiple systems
to protect people from these kinds of outcomes, but it's being
carried mainly by salacious culture war rightoids who want to
take advantage of an innocent white girl getting by a black guy.
Even you guys decided to needlessly play the tape of her murder
as though that provides any substantive context. We have become
so desensitized to violence that for over 2 minutes after this
poor woman was stabbed, no one did a damn thing. That's not being
desensitized like everyone on that train plays too much Call
of Duty. That's threat avoidance. The guy has a knife and if
they saw what happened, they're probably in shock because survival
in Wait, I think a lot of those a lot of those people didn't
see what happened until he was like making his way through that
car, right? There's a guy who's like standing with his back to
him and I feel like if other people knew that he had a knife,
if other people really like comprehended what was going on, people
would have said, "Hey, buddy, spin. You're about to be in trouble."
Cuz if that guy wanted to get a second victim, there's some dude
with his back to him like as he's walking by. >> instincts
kick in that tell you to avoid danger. There was one thing in
the old days that was a good thing. That was when people looked
out for one another and and men would be men. A man is supposed
to protect. Sorry, but that's that's just reality. >> point,
the story of Kitty Genovese is more of an urban legend of people
failing to help someone than a real tragic murder, but it's a
good example of the fact that there are no good old days of traditional
gender roles playing out in their ideal form. We can only do
the best we can with the circumstances we're given and we shouldn't
put pressure on people to act in situations they're unprepared
for. I'm not putting it on you that it hey, the guy's got a >> At
least like apprehend the guy in some way so he doesn't potentially
hurt someone else. Nope, no bad idea. Getting into a fight with
a guy who's holding a knife is a good way to get You're not Liam
Neeson. Aw.
I can see exactly why
uh so many things are making This is all
I can see why he doesn't like the anti-neoliberal propaganda.
Um he's not even wrong on some of these things, but the way he
argues them are like very um
uh it's like
it's just I don't know how to describe it other than neoliberal
coded or like it it's
I feel like a bunch of people
on the left would would understand if I said he's like an abundance
he sounds like an abundance liberal type, the exact kind that
Anna complains about.
But it's not really a substantial criticism. It's like a vibe
that I'm that I'm sensing. >> Neeson, you don't know how
to expertly put a guy in a wrist lock to disarm them. Going after
a guy with a knife is a great way to split a paramedic's time
between two people instead of one. We finally get to Israel and
I'm very divided. Maybe it's just that my bar for good coverage
has fallen so far the devil is using it as a limbo pole, but
the coverage is much more substantial and yet also because of
that somehow worse. At least while I'm watching, they cover the
factual news of an Israeli airstrike on Qatar that was targeting
the negotiators Israel is communicating with to end the war,
but where they draw conclusions, they find conspiracy. For example,
Genk recalls covering an Israeli American sniper who was secretly
recorded in an interview where he admits his unit likely total
of 105 people and confirms a significant number, if not all,
were either unarmed or clearly civilians and not a threat. Yesterday
we showed a a guy
Clips are out of order here. secretly recorded in an interview
where he admits his unit likely total of 105 people and confirms
a significant number, if not all, were either unarmed or clearly
civilians and not a threat. Yesterday we showed a a guy who sounded
exactly like an SS soldier bragging about how he 105 Palestinians
with no weapons that were defenseless. They'd simply stepped
over an invisible arbitrary line their group had established
as a kill zone, but then he'll go from that legitimate series
of war crimes which should be fully investigated, condemned,
and adjudicated to and that's why Israel runs the United States
government. When was the last time they passed a law that helped
the super rich or corporations or foreign governments? Endlessly,
endlessly. Then the minute they come back to us, they're like,
"We don't have any money left. We we gave it all to Exxon Mobil
and Pfizer and Israel." And it completely undermines him. They'll
say that Israel shouldn't have conducted the airstrike on Qatar,
but then they'll go on to say that Israel shouldn't be conducting
counteroffensives against any of the belligerent actors in the
region who had been attacking them for months. Israel feels that
they
What do you mean Okay, but like
there's no way this guy's like, "Oh, they'll argue that Israel
should stop hitting the terrorist cells around them." It's like,
"Bro, you won. You got What What did Genk say? I think Genk was
on Piers recently. He was like, "120 October 7ths at this point
or Like you guys won. You guys won completely. It's over. You've
decimated every other power in the region completely. Like it's
over. You won. You can stop now. You can stop now. You don't
have to keep killing people. It's fine. You can stop anytime.
>> They are entitled to bomb or carry out strikes in any
sovereign country they feel like. They'll compare civilian to
combatant ratios and conclude Israel is therefore worse than
Assad's Syria. The ratio is significantly worse than worse than
what Assad did in Syria, worse than almost any terrorist activity
in terms of percentage of civilians or at least that it's even
worth comparing when the population density and intentions of
the actors in these places are nothing alike. I'm with them in
the setup.
And then they lose me in the conclusion. So if you're negotiating
for peace Listen, you don't understand. Those civilians are packed
in there like sardines. How are you supposed to anyone without
killing civilians? That's impossible. Have you thought of the
population density of Gaza? It's really hard to throw a J dam
in there and not kill child. We have to throw the J dams in there.
We can't possibly stop. >> Peace. You're obviously not
going to get peace. Is BB solely responsible for peace negotiations
falling through? Yes is winning overwhelmingly as it should.
It is an empirical fact. >> goes on to compare to Osama
bin Laden Just like bin Laden. Okay, wait. to imply that Israel
has less justification to go after because they have more legitimacy
to the Palestinians and were negotiating for the hostages, which
is not the argument I would be making if I wanted to make it
clear that the Palestinians are not all and to be clear, I'm
not making that argument either. has won an election before.
But wait a minute, the Israeli government is bigger terrorist
than That's empirical. You can catch feelings over it. I I I
don't care. Fine, I guess we're doing this. Was initially a charity
called Mujama al-Islamiyya founded by Sheikh Yasin
I I feel like he should just grab the LonerBox video when he
wants to do this. I think that would be like a better play. It's
to just grab the LonerBox >> 1973 to build infrastructure
in Gaza like doctors' offices and daycares. They would also encourage
women to wear hijabs and attack left-wing organizations like
the Palestinian Red Crescent Society due to what they described
as immorality. Israel, as it would later be revealed, funded
this group as they saw it as a counter to the PLO in order to
fracture any political unity in Gaza to prevent the formation
of an official state. Where Mujama al-Islamiyya was religious
and conservative, the PLO was secular. This was an extremely
bad idea as it turns out for a number of reasons, not the least
of which are the repercussions it had on Israeli civilians and
the devastation to Gazan society that facilitated entrenchment.
Some take this as an opportunity to place all of the blame for
on Israel and while Israel shouldn't have put itself in a position
to bear any of the responsibility, they could only try to take
advantage of existing sent
Wait, is this his response to like is BB
Okay, is this his response to the IDF are bigger terrorists than
or is this his response
to BB is responsible for the war continuing? Back when they did
the strike in Gaza the same way right-wing Christian nationalists
in the United States didn't create the Likud party. So, in 1984,
the Israeli military discovered a stockpile of weapons at one
of their mosques and arrested Sheikh Yasin, but he was released
in 1985 in an agreement to trade Palestinian prisoners for IDF
hostages of the 1982 Lebanon War. In 1987, Sheikh Yasin started
as a paramilitary wing of the Muslim Brotherhood. Yahya Sinwar
would be charged with finding any Palestinians who were collaborators
with Israel. In 1989, after carrying out their first attack,
Yahya Sinwar would be given four life sentences for planning
out the abduction and murder of two Israeli soldiers and four
Palestinians he saw as collaborators. Yasin was arrested again
and after hundreds of activists were deported to Lebanon, the
group began dealings with Hezbollah. Then in 1992, they created
the al-Qassam Brigades to oppose the 1993 Oslo Accords, the compact
between Israel and the PLO that would hopefully create a bridge
to peace. After the Cave of the Patriarch Massacre, wherein American-Israeli
settler Baruch Goldstein 29 unarmed civilians and injured over
100 more in Hebron, began targeting civilians directly. In 1999,
was banned from Jordan by King Abdullah to ensure peace negotiations
with Israel did not fall apart. In 2000, after the failure of
the Camp David Summit, launches the Second Intifada. About 100
bombings are carried out in Israel. The IDF thousands. In 2004,
Sheikh Yasin and another official offered a truce in exchange
for the establishment of a Palestinian state that governed East
Jerusalem, the West Bank, and Gaza. Israel them both a few months
later. It's unclear whether their offer was sincere. In 2005,
the Second Intifada ends. The IDF withdraws from Gaza while maintaining
sea and airspace control. In
ran as a political party in elections to Palestinian Parliament
Again, this is the answer to I think the IDF is a bigger terrorist
organization
on a platform of violent resistance against Israel. From there,
the US and EU conditioned aid to the Palestinians on renouncing
violence, recognizing Israel, and endorsing the peace process
outlined in the Oslo Accords. rejected this. By 2007, had completely
ousted Fatah and the PLO from Gaza with at least 600 people being
killed in the fighting between them. This is all on Wikipedia,
by the way. If you're reporting on this stuff, you can just look
it up. Israel begins a strict blockade on Gaza. Cultural repression
and totalitarian rule by is strict. In the following years, there's
a cycle of clashes, ceasefires, and Israeli incursions into Gaza.
In an effort at slowly improving relations, Israel would issue
work permits for Palestinians to enter Israel, and Qatari aid
money was allowed into Gaza in the hopes of improving conditions
to temper extremism. In 2011, Yahya Sinwar is released with over
a thousand others in a prisoner exchange. In 2017, updates its
charter, and Trump recognizes Jerusalem as the capital of Takes
that as a declaration of war. In 2018, there is the Great March
of Return. Independent activists begin a protest of weekly marches
to the border between Gaza and Israel in protest of Israel's
blockade and for a right of return of refugees. Thousands join
the protests intending to be nonviolent. However, there were
those in the protests who did engage in violence, some throwing
stones and Molotov cocktails, others firing rifles or throwing
bombs. The circumstances behind the violence across the months
of protest are foggy. But, at the risk of being crude in my brevity,
it was basically some protesters escalating to provoke a response
and the IDF not knowing how to aim. Thousands were injured by
IDF gunfire and about 180
claimed 50 as killed.
IDF not knowing how to aim. Huh. Seems like it would be kind
of an important thing for like a army. Like a literally a an
army.
But, you know what? Let's >> the Abraham Let's Let's just
throw that out what out there.
Dude, it's basically like some people really were like escalating
to try to get a response and the IDF didn't know how to aim,
man. That's why they took out the knee joints so perfectly of
so many children. >> Accords are announced and signed.
The UAE, Bahrain, Sudan, and Morocco recognize Israel. In 2023,
on October 7th, over a thousand people in Israel takes over 200
hostage and the war in Gaza begins. Peace negotiations are frequently
stalled by intransigence and Israeli belligerence. The main sticking
point of the negotiation would be whether could stay in power
without disarming. By October 2025, at least 65,000 Palestinians
have been and over 150,000 have been injured. The ratio is significantly
worse than a Worse than what Assad did in Syria? October 7th
ratio is a meaningless statistic when it was an unprovoked attack
intended to draw the IDF into Gaza with the intention of fighting
a prolonged siege. >> Using that
Uh wait, why does he think it was an intent Why does he think
that was the intent to get Israel to siege Gaza?
I don't know I don't know if he thinks that that was the or I
don't know if that was like their intent. I mean, obviously that's
a side effect. But, you don't know that they don't want to like
pull those people in so they can negotiate and not have Israel
like totally [__] with them. I I assume that's why
they took so many hostages.
Um not to defend any of the actions, obviously. October 7th disgusting.
>> logic? Well, yeah, we murdered the entire government
of Yemen. The Houthis that were One, the Houthis are not Yemen's
government. Two, this is a terrible argument for proportionate
response given the level of escalation from the Houthis towards
Israel and the surrounding countries who have been impacted by
their blockade over a year and a half since it started. By your
own standard, this was restraint. >> The sniper who's murdering
all those innocent Palestinians, he said that he was one of the
guys on a college campus in America that said his feelings were
>> here is that Daniel Rob was on campus sometime after
2023, but he graduated in 2021 and his complaints of anti-Semitism
do have some substantive backing, though that's now all rightly
called into question by his actions in Gaza. We've lost all faith
in our institutions. They They are They are worthless. What's
the last time Congress passed a law that helped us?
Our next segment is about Seinfeld comparing pro-Palestine protesters
to the clan.
I mean, I think Cenk would So, with all of those infrastructure
bills,
the infrastructure plan, inflation He's going to say a whole
bunch of these were like um
not directly targeting people and they were like benefiting major
corporations as well. I mean, it's both. The CHIPS and Science
Like I can I can love this CHIPS and Science Act from like every
single goal it accomplished and like like what it accomplished
and how well it did it. But, it's like not um it's not like programs
for the people, right? It's funding. It's like uh
like checking China's power, China's progress into like I I don't
know like chip research and stuff. It's a really great thing,
but I just I don't think it's um helping the people in the way
that Cenk's arguing for. Which like is why we don't listen to
Cenk, basically. Our next segment is about Seinfeld comparing
pro-Palestine protesters to the clan because at least the clan
is outspoken about not liking Jews. Comedian Jerry Seinfeld has
unfortunately and tragically reached new levels of depravity.
Worse than the time he dated a >> It is not difficult to
distinguish
between a foreign government
and a foreign military
and the entirety
of an identity of a group of people. Okay, for me it's not hard
at all. >> Then why are you so bad at it? So, you have
singled out a Jewish person who has called out, albeit too coarsely,
the anti-Semitism of the pro-Palestine >> What they are
UIJ hate hour? Um
Yeah, a little bit.
We're watching this guy. This guy made
like a pretty bad video into Hasan.
And it was really like poorly put together. This one's better.
Although, I might Listen, I might just be uh I might be just,
you know, big time EP at the end of the night. But, I think this
one's this one's at least got like better points it's making.
Like more tangible points. >> effectively communicating
to the world is that anyone who has a problem with genocidal
acts is by definition an anti-Semite. I don't personally believe
that anti-Semitism is inherent to being pro-Palestine, but a
lot of the loudest voices and a lot of the imagery has colored
them that way because the leaders of the movement haven't done
a good enough job of honing their message. Instead, we got
Uh this is just not true. Um I Okay, this is the part where you're
like totally coping, okay?
You're totally coping. Way more I I guarantee you way more people
who have any sort of presence online, any sort of like media
understanding, anybody who's like on social media at all,
definitely has concerns about Israel far more than the free Palestine
movement. Um they just totally won. Like you've totally lost
as Israel. Like the the the Democrat the left-wing opinion of
Israel has gone into the
because of their actions.
So, like to say that the free Palestine movement has worse optics
than the country of Israel or to to say it's got like the optics
that make people think it's like the Ku Klux Klan, I think most
people at this point after seeing the numbers of Palestinian
dead, they're like, "Oh, you know what? I'm I might have misjudged
those people." >> anti-Semite. I don't personally believe
that anti-Semitism is inherent to being pro-Palestine, but a
lot of the loudest voices and a lot of the imagery has colored
them Is this This is the uh is this the Hezbollah flag? I think.
Is the Hezbollah flag, right? So, these people have Hezbollah
flags, so I think you're anti-Semitic, I guess, is the >> that way
because the leaders of the movement haven't done a good enough
job of honing their message. In
You think Fuentes cares about Palestinians or just hates Israel?
It's definitely just hates Israel.
>> Instead, we got humanitarian aid pizza, storming of
Columbia, and fights with police. All actions that have centered
on the protesters instead of Palestine >> He's unintentionally
making anti-Semitism seem like a good >> Whether or not
you believe in the prevalence of anti-Semitism there is, at this
point, the selfishness of it is undeniable. And so, Jerry Seinfeld,
it turns out, is a racist and thinks, "No, Palestinians should
be forever enslaved by Israel." And Cenk and Ana doubling down
on the vitriol that pushed people away is just more of the same.
Or imprisoned in the occupied territories by my moral beloved
Israel, okay? They're dark. They're like I don't I don't free
Palestine. Why would I would free a bunch of I'm not saying that
because I think Seinfeld's words were good. >> To be Bro,
what? Okay, why does Why does Warski have massive
[__] on? Can somebody
I just noticed Kino Casino's live. I like pulled up a preview
window for a quick second and noticed Warski's got
[__] on. It's Warski, isn't it? Uh is >> Jesus
Christ. >> is making up. By the way, He's been streaming
for how long? In the past like like like every day? What the
[__] is that? Every day? For like four Yeah, for
like four hours a day.
As [__] disturbing, okay? That's incredibly [__]
disturbing. Jesus
Anyway, back to this video. >> over disgusting racist.
Frankly, I think he said a lot of stuff that's been at best ignorant.
Wait, why would I would free a bunch of I'm not saying that because
I think Seinfeld's words were good. >> To be an over disgusting
racist. Frankly, I think he said a lot of
Anti-Semitic vandals graffiti included
symbol for targeted killings on Brooklyn Museum director's front
door.
Okay. stuff that's been at best ignorant. A A, yes, he's obviously
racist. B, no, if you want to free Palestinians, that means you're
more hateful than the KKK. And I think he's become a little too
disconnected to have an opinion worth listening to, but he's
an adult and extremely wealthy, so he can take care of himself.
>> Jerry Seinfeld loves Palestinians. Whoever wants to
freedom hates the My point is that what Seinfeld said isn't worth
this much time to tear Seinfeld down instead of lifting Palestine
up. >> What a terrible thing to say not just
Did this guy Wait, did this guy just
There's no way this guy went "Uh are you really going to criticize
Jerry Seinfeld when there's a genocide going on? Is there It
There's no way this guy is like a neoliberal type just did the
Hasan line to TYT, right? That's a joke. I think that's a joke.
I'm going to give him I'm going to give it two minutes to say
that's clearly a joke and that he's uh he's meaning right there
and he's going to go, "Just kidding, I'd never make that argument."
>> What about Palestinians? What about Jews? No, I know
tons of I wouldn't call it a one-to-one comparison, but not too
long ago in this stream, they were extremely concerned about
people raising the temperature because it'll only cause more
problems and that's Um do you really think it's appropriate to
criticize Jerry Seinfeld when there's a genocide going on? So,
this segment is really for bunch of savages. He's like one of
the most racist guys in America. I guess he's a Jew supremacist.
Apparently, Jerry Seinfeld's parents were probably monsters and
they told him to hate Palestinians. Next, the UK ambassador to
America was fired because his close ties to Jeffrey Epstein were
revealed. And so, Cenk assumes that he was appointed to be controlled
by Israel. Because him being involved in the Epstein case wasn't
a bug, it was a feature. They picked him because they knew that
he could be trusted to do right by a certain country. And that
country is not Great Britain and it is not America. But, it's
certainly NOT
THEN FOR SOME REASON, we get
Ana, you're supposed to do the face. Do the Do the grabbler hands,
Ana, right now. The letter written by a guy named Rabbi Shmuley
trying to solicit donations off of Charlie Kirk's death. The
business isn't bringing in the >> I just want to be clear,
they're kosher.
Oh, okay. Okay. I mean, look, I have no problem with the sale
of if if what you're into. >> Oh, who sells kosher things?
Uh and defense genocide? Right, what I think is more or less
the accurate 9/11 history, that's anti-Semitic. Suggesting that
9/11 could have been done by anybody else, anti-Semitic.
Wow. If you criticize Israel, they were the ones who did the
hit. Did Israel Who was Israel I think? The That shooter is long
gone, got a plane back to Israel.
Today, the FBI arrested someone who was planning to murder journalists
who he considered the enemy of the people. Jay, where do you
think he got that idea? Calling them the enemy of the people
encourages violence against them. Every time he puts out a tweet
saying enemy of the people, he increases the percentage chance
that somebody at the New York Times is going to get Donald Trump
will go after any type of medium. Late night comedy show, Donald
Trump wanted to look into SNL because they make fun of him. If
I, in some alternate universe, were a Ooh, if this is if they
totally flip on
with the Kimmel thing, I would be shocked. I don't think they
did though. They must have been super disgusted with Trump over
the Kimmel thing. The only saving grace would be like I'm I'm
guessing Anna focused on like Ted Cruz. Ted Cruz was like a moderating
voice in the Republican Party for this. >> right-winger
who had supported I'm guessing that would make a lot of people
see you. Like if you went, "Well, I really like Ted Cruz's approach
to make sure that he's like holding the Republicans accountable."
I think saying that would make some certain people see >> won the
election. At this very moment, I would be deeply embarrassed
>> And and what does he do like all cowards? He says, "Well,
I don't I don't want to get into a fight, right? I mean I got
bone spurs. OH, I GOT BONE SPURS. BONE SPURS. AND INCREDIBLY
THIN SKIN so I can't go into any fight. But you know what? Somebody
should do something about the enemy of the people." And he encourages
other people to take actions that are going to lead to violence.
If you don't know calling someone the enemy of the people, especially
when you're the president of the United States, encourages violence,
either you're totally lying, you know it encourages violence
and you're hoping somebody gets hurt at the New York Times, or
you're the dumbest person in America. So, here we are. Another
right-wing terrorist targeting journalists and liberals because
he thought they were against Trump. Is it connected to his tweets?
God damn right it is. All right, time for day two. Anna, before
we get started, how are you doing? >> Don't ask me that
cuz it's not good, but let's just move on. Let's get I'm just
really sad at like where the country is right now. You know,
what's happening in the Middle East, obviously I've been worried
about that, but it does break my heart that some of the most
prominent streamers, content creators have been putting out some
stuff out that
I don't know where I belong. Has not called for continued violence
against the right. >> So, what changed between foreshadowing
and today? I'm an enormous believer that the radicals do not
represent the left
Uh, this is going to be I hope you guys are ready for it. You
You all know what it is, right? It's pretty obvious to me what
it is. >> More both-sidesing. Okie dokie. It really didn't
take long for members of the Trump administration to exploit
the murder of Charlie Kirk to essentially roll back rights of
Americans under this guise of fighting terrorism. How are you
going to both-sides this one, Anna? I am personally disgusted
with the celebrations of Charlie Kirk's murder. You know, years
ago I How is this Wait, how is this
Wait, how can it be Hold on. Where Where is she equating?
Where Where is she equating here? "I don't like that people celebrate
Charlie Kirk's murder." is a gen- general sent- sentiment. And
now she's like But on the other side, she's explicitly criticizing
the government and the policies they're putting into
Those aren't the same.
>> You could talk about both of them. Doesn't mean you're
both-sidesing the >> Turning Point USA and how they literally
had published a list of professors for people to target. But
I do think we need to have some sort of regulation that prevents
doxing from happening. But see, that would be, you know, trying
to find a reasonable solution to an ongoing problem that I've
seen on both the left and the right. >> but we should do
something, but not about that specifically. A different problem
that they aren't trying to address. But that's not what Stephen
Miller and the Trump administration are interested in doing here.
>> Now, whether you believe him or not, Charlie Kirk's
number one issue was free speech. You could say, "Hey, you know,
I found instances where he was >> This has me wondering,
would a voting qualify as an act of speech if it's done anonymously,
but it's taken as the voice of the people in the selection of
their leadership? That might be a question for the philosophers,
but January 6th definitely proves that both Trump and Kirk do
not care about what people's opinions actually are if they're
willing to subvert them to their own ends. But it doesn't matter.
I mean, they're fascists. Yeah, sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. You could
do this. And I do think we made the same argument, right? That
basically these guys are authoritarians. See you later, Kiriako.
These guys are authoritarians. They're They're like actually
quasi-fascists. Charlie Kirk supports a quasi-fascist like administration,
quasi moving towards like actual fascism as fast as they possibly
can. And so there's probably some argument that like, yeah, he
doesn't really respect freedom of speech. And it's just like
an act while they slowly take things over. Right? I think that's
fair. You still don't advocate for him to be
And I do think it's like a little to go like, "At least Charlie
debated with
But I mean, if it Is it the most I don't know. It's like not
really criticizable
on its own to say like, "Well, at least this guy tried talking."
matter. He wanted his legacy to be free speech. They The right
wing believe that his legacy is free speech. >> think that's
how that works. Does George Bush's legacy get to be his time
as a >> Ran two elections on that, 2020 and 2024. Source?
Please? But now you're in power and all of a sudden we're going
to cancel people? No, it's not canceling someone when you bring
the weight of the federal government down on someone. That's
a fair bit more. It's a violation of your constitutional and
civil rights. This is exactly how you lose your freedom. And
then if the Democrats get back in charge, then the two sides
will flip and then the right will go, "No, no, more free speech.
No, no, cancel culture." And the left will go back to
Wasn't Cenk criticizing the right for running two elections on
free speech? Like the COVID campaign they would have run and
then right after the COVID campaign, the next one being like,
"Oh, Kamala Harris is going to crack down on free speech everywhere."
Did he think that Cenk was criticizing the left there? Maybe
I dude, I never >> wanted his legacy to be free speech.
They The right wing believe that his legacy is free speech. >> I don't
think that's how that works. Does George Bush's legacy get to
be his time as a painter? >> Ran two elections on that,
2020 and 2024. Source?
Please? But now you're in power and all of a sudden Source that
like they ran on this as a significant issue? Absolutely in 2020.
I think they ran on it significantly in 2024 as well. The whole
idea that the left's like cracked down on all these people. Yeah,
I think they ran on that for sure. Is that like a like a confusing
point?
That's like a lot of the free speech stuff. Oh, you don't even
You won't even let us say there's two genders. Like that whole
thing, you'll cancel people for this. >> sudden we're going
to cancel people? No, it's not canceling someone when you bring
the weight of the federal government down on someone. That's
a fair bit more. It's a violation of your constitutional and
civil rights. This is exactly how you lose your freedom. And
then if the Democrats get back in charge, then the two sides
will flip and then the right will go, "No, no, more free speech.
No, no, cancel culture." And the left will go back to "Oh, no,
no more free speech." >> You can't even improvise what
the realistic expectation of a Democratic administration curtailing
free speech would look like. I never thought I would ever fear
the law
I mean the COVID campaign, the COVID
That's what it looked like?
Um, you could you could say
nonsensically cracking down on free speech and then maybe that's
a little harder cuz you could probably argue the COVID crackdowns
made some sense. But like that's obviously a crackdown on free
speech. >> of our liberal democracy, but for the first
time ever I'm actually fearful of that. I really am. >> wild
to admit this one. That's what everyone was talking about prior
to the election and you didn't take it >> You know, I laughed
about it. How laughable is it to think that Americans would want
to be ruled by a monarchy? And the whole point of a liberal democracy
is to allow you to articulate your arguments, make a case for
your >> Wow, it would be really surprising if Donald Trump
made it clear way before the election that he wasn't a fan of
liberal democracy. And whatever you might think about Charlie
Kirk, he provided a platform for people to do >> Cenk said
when you die you don't become an angel, but they are certainly
doing the work to rewrite what Kirk's actual job was. The entire
point of college campus debates was to position media-trained
conservatives against inexperienced students to create an image
of intelligence and superiority. The point wasn't to exchange
ideas, it was to have people offer themselves as a metaphorical
sacrifice to the discourse. And so they said But people say,
"Well, he was trying to influence people in the wrong direction."
That's right. That's why we're here trying to influence people
in the right direction. And that's called America. >> I
kind of agree with that, actually. When people are acting in
good faith, and Charlie Kirk was not. >> You fight back
with words, you fight back politically, you fight back with rhetoric.
And if anyone on the right actually meant anything about freedom
of speech that they said, they would be 100% opposed to what
Steven Miller just said. Okay, but they're not. Not even Charlie
Kirk because Kirk supported Trump and Trump supported Miller.
And after Trump brought on Miller, he continued to support him.
This isn't difficult. It's like you say, words and actions. And
now we get to a group
Uh, I think like Charlie Kirk could certainly disagree. And before
this administration, I don't think there was like a lot Was there
a lot of like explicit crackdowns on free speech? Here's the
unfortunate thing that nobody wants to admit, okay? The things
Charlie Kirk was was fine with in terms of cracking down on free
speech were all in favor of Israel. All right, it was all the
anti-Semitism laws that they were trying to put into place. It
was those crackdowns. Okay, black-bagging protesters on university
campuses. That's what Charlie Kirk endorsed.
But I don't think this guy wants to say
Uh group of right-wing trolls that decided to create a website
for harassing people that made light of Charlie Kirk's death.
I'm actually kind of amazed at what their response is, starting
with they learned it from the left. Right-wing activists and
some politicians are on a bit of a witch hunt. And I think some
of the behavior that we saw, you know, beginning in 2020, if
anything, I would say that the
Isn't that a great criticism though? Is that like there was like
this progressive lefty cancel culture thing that was happening?
That wasn't like a majority of people who are liberal. But there
was a like lefty cancel culture thing that was going on 20 I
don't know, 17 to 2020
ish.
And and they basically all whined about it for like years and
years and years. Asmongold,
every single person, every anti-Gamergate person,
We call them anti-Gamergaters. Whatever. Everybody on Asmongold's
side of this issue, they They complained about this [__]
for years and then they started using the same playbook. It was
embarrassing for them. I think it was a criticism or sorry, it
was a playbook they criticized when it was used against them.
>> right is learning from those tactics and now going on
a witch hunt against Charlie Kirk's critics. Where did you get
this? Who taught you how to use this thing? You, all right? I
learned from watching you.
Just be careful about what you're posting online. Be thoughtful
about what you're putting out there. >> That is actually
good advice. Oh, well, why don't you condemn Trump for refusing
to turn the temperature down? Listen, I have accepted a long
time ago that Donald Trump is never going to be a leader in regard
to having cooler heads prevail so things don't kind of spiral
out of control where we have even more violence. Why have you
accepted that? But even if Biden or Kamala Harris said it, they
wouldn't listen anyway. >> Right now, Americans are struggling
regardless of where they stand on the political aisle, okay?
>> It's an explanation to say that people under increased
stress act out more, but that shouldn't be touted as an excuse
for people choosing to harass someone. Like it's the equivalent
of taking a kickboxing class. And what are the political elite
doing right now? They are directing our ire at one another. No,
only one side is doing that. And then to both sides of that,
Anna brings up the 2022 mass shooting in Buffalo, New York by
a white supremacist. Go into a grocery store in Buffalo, New
York and gun down 10 black Americans. That was politically motivated
violence. Can we please stop pretending like there isn't a problem
in this country on both sides? There is a problem right now.
There is. There just is. We've been saying on this show, stop
calling all Trump voters
Wait, where Wait, where did she find the the left-wing violence?
What was her example of left-wing violence? It There's no way
she picked the Buffalo
I'm like in and out a little bit. There's no way she said, "Oh,
the Buffalo shooter is an example of left-wing violence, right?"
>> are directing our ire at one another. No, only one side
is doing that. And then to both sides of that, Anna brings up
the 2022 mass shooting in Buffalo, New York by a white sup
So, Vaush has never done this? Vaush has never done stochastic
terrorism. I want this guy to admit Vaush has never encouraged
people to possibly arm themselves for violent resistance. Vaush
has never done a stochastic terrorism. Vaush is on Vaush's character,
Vaush's you know, uh
character as a political actor is
>> is Go into a grocery store in Buffalo, New York and
gun down 10 black Americans. That was politically motivated violence.
Can By the way, I still think that the right wing's like a like
way way way way way worse. There's just like two There's like
a couple people, okay? Trump keeps getting shot at that like
kind of weighs it back in the other direction, but not >> stop
pretending like there isn't a problem in this country on both
sides? There is a problem right now. There is. There just is.
We've been saying on this show, stop calling all Trump voters
>> Trump supporters, not all racist, but all supporters
of racists. No one is doing nuance anymore at all. We've just
got both sides saying, "Nope, I'm going to find the most extreme
person on that side and make them the poster child." Well, the
most extreme people on the right currently have control of the
federal government, Cenk. Cenk reads a viewer comment. >> Israel
is a major player in the That's so not true. That's so not true.
Okay? It could be Listen, it's really bad. It's really really
bad. There are some people with some very extreme right-wing
opinions that have a lot of power.
But it's not the worst.
you'd have very different policy with regards to Israel if uh
if the worst people on the right had power there, okay? >> culture.
They're also a significant cause of the desensitization online.
They've blurred all standards for moral morality, humanity, respect,
integrity. Program. That's what I call the Israelification of
the world, which is if you're strong and powerful, you don't
have to follow the law, you don't have to follow morality, and
call it self-defense and laugh. >> The word you're looking
for is Russification. Then they touch on rumors about Kash Patel
feuding with Pam Bondi and potentially getting ousted as FBI
director. Fox multiple sources also told Fox that Patel was forcibly
instructed not to speak, adding that investigators had still
not identified a suspect. Next up is Florida Congressman Brian
Mast putting up a bill that would allow Secretary of State Marco
Rubio to revoke someone's passport if they're critical of Israel.
A man, by the way, who showed up to the halls of Congress wearing
an IDF uniform. Just kind of gives you a sense of This is uh
this is the kind of thing that Charlie Kirk supports, okay? >> How much
control this foreign government has over our own lawmakers. And
it might have to do something with just how much money they take
from the Israel Oh, come on. How is this guy going to push back
against this point? >> is quite a bit. >> Representative
Mast is not a US representative. He served in the IDF. Mast did
not serve in the IDF. He did volunteer work packing medical kits.
It's an important distinction. Mast lost both his legs in Afghanistan
in 2010. He would not have been able to serve in an official
capacity as a soldier. But that's how he got the uniform he wore
in 2023 after the October 7th attacks. American taxpayers do
give give give give to the country that representative
He's wearing a military uniform from another country. Remember
how badly people swiped out when Trump saluted a general from
another country? It's like I You don't want somebody wearing
another country's uniform, military uniform, in Congress as a
congressman. >> actually loves, which is Israel. Brian
Mast is an evangelical Christian. That's why he likes Israel.
However, I want to kind of get to the root of something that
I see as a huge problem in this country, namely the ability of
government officials to slap the label of terrorist onto pretty
much anyone. How do you even determine what terrorist is? Like
what is the definition? What are the guidelines that government
officials would be using to designate someone as a terrorist?
Well, it's super vague and can be applied
Uh it's weird that this guy wore an IDF uniform to Congress,
you know? He served in the IDF. He didn't serve in the IDF. Okay,
was it weird for him to wear the uniform? Mm.
Mm. He's an evangelical Christian. That's okay. >> applied
pretty generously to anyone, including someone who's been kidnapped,
forcibly kidnapped by a guerrilla group, and you know, is is
now deemed a supporter of terrorism because of the fact that
she was forced to cook and clean for that group. It's crazy.
Absolutely insane. In the middle of this super serious story,
I just idea of her serving gorillas as in apes rather than
Okay, if you're aiding and abetting gorillas or orangutans We
were so close to decent coverage of one story. No, we have a
First Amendment as much as Israel and the corrupt US politicians
who serve Israel might hate that. >> But all that comfortably
leads into more Israel news that's basically just an excuse to
How do I put this? Well, you saw the clip earlier, so let's just
say embrace their inner Fuentes. When I heard TikTok update their
terms of service to no longer allow violence / gory videos, I
thought, "There it is. There's the Israeli play in all of this.
They're going to take not only Kirk's death down, but all the
Gaza / West Bank deaths as well." The beginning of the new week,
that's it. All the Israeli forces inside the US government and
inside social media attacking. >> Well, unfortunately,
the United States is currently in bed with savage terrorists,
and that is the current government of Israel. But um Is it Wait.
Where where I don't think this guy knows anything that Fuentes
says. People compare Dude,
the annexation of the West Bank. The annexation of land
Is it Is it really like like leftists are that offensive to people
that they'll whitewash Nick Fuentes? And I find Nick funny, okay?
But like they'll whitewash his opinions, they'll make it seem
like his opinions are not that bad by trying to compare him to
like leftists who are just saying they hate Israel or they're
mad at Israel for conducting what I think we all agree is at
minimum an ethnic cleansing, something bordering on a genocide
at minimum, right?
And he's going to compare that to Fuentes, I guess. Also, what
the music did you give me, by the way? Are you >> in Syria
following the fall of Bashar al-Assad. I was technically incorrect
in my Hazan video. And despite bombing Syria, the IDF has actively
removed Israelis who have tried to set up settlements across
the border. Well, Israel hasn't allowed civilians to settle in
regions of the Golan Heights past the border. After the fall
of Assad, the IDF
Loader Box says this is not a genocide. Uh it's getting close,
uh but I listen, I don't even fight over that because it's stupid,
right? It's like insane wanton slaughter that nobody could conscience
anymore. Like nobody could, you know, it would with any good
conscience support.
Just just absolute disgusting
totally callous lack of concern for human beings that leads to
them just being slaughtered en masse.
Right? Like and they're being ethnically cleansed at minimum.
I don't I don't feel like Loader Box is like supporting the IDF
and like their actions for the past 3 months. We'll We'll see.
expanded their buffer zone, which while questionably legal, makes
sense given that Syria had just opposed their government and
wasn't fully capable of enforcing a new stability. What Anna
is describing makes it sound like they set up an entirely new
West Bank-style settlement. And while that cannot be completely
ruled out in the future and should be criticized that Uh did
they move out and take that mountain? I assume that's what they
did,
They went and took that mountain so they could get that airstrip
up in the highlands right there, like north of uh
Right? That's what they moved in. Hold
Let me see here. Where's Where is this at? Israeli buffer zone,
Syria.
I assume they just moved out and took the actual military objective
they wanted, right?
So, there's like um there's some mountaintop that's like north
of
There's some mountaintop that's north of
the Golan Heights. Oh, this is not Wait,
Israel has expanded its occupation of the Syrian Golan Heights
this week by seizing a UN-supervised demilitarized buffer zone
hours after the downfall of the Assad regime. Oh, this is an
old article, though. I'm looking for a picture of this. Give
me a second.
Where do we find it here? Looking for where they pushed out because
basically there's um Wait, what is this from? The Intercept?
I don't know. I don't know, man.
Oh, this is way different.
Is it totally different thing? There's like a There's basically
a place where they're going to try to build up like some military
standing around this mountain so that they can control the airspace
around northern Israel more effectively. Then, there's no evidence
that the Israeli government wants that to happen now. >> This
is an expansionist colonial settler program, the Greater Israel
project, and anyone trying to convince you otherwise is lying
to you. >> Greater Israel isn't a thing. It won't ever
be a thing. Cannot ever reasonably be a thing. If you want to
talk about expansion in Gaza and the West Bank, by all means
criticize it, condemn it, call the conditions an apartheid. But
like I said last time, Greater Israel is taking land they can't
hold with forces they don't have, with aid they won't get. >> This
is about aiding and abetting Israel's empire building. To be
fair to he did try hard to get the peace in >> Trump tried
to get peace What? >> And I believe he tried in Gaza. Yeah,
Trump Gaza number one. That's what that means, right? Right?
But that all changed after Netanyahu
Wait, what? Yeah, I don't know I don't know how much he tried
Listen, his his opening salvo for Ukraine was like uh listen,
Zelensky, just surrender or we're not going to give you weapons,
okay? We'll we'll just totally abandon you. Surrender right now.
That was his opening. I don't know how much that's like going
for peace. I feel like that's really unfair to call that like
going for peace. Who's last visit? We we don't know what happened
there, but Trump went from challenging them to doing the same
exact obedient lapdog routine as Joe Biden. I gave them too much
credit yesterday. So, when they say all of us have to surrender,
that is a purposely undoable goal. I mean, this technically could
be correct. Given their religious fanaticism and the number of
people they've already forced in front of gunfire, it's hard
to say whether you could actually get them to surrender. How
do they surrender? Do a couple hundred people, a couple thousand
people come out of the tunnels dressed in their garb? And no
one even knows what it means to surrender. Do they just kill
themselves? Do they turn themselves into Israeli authorities?
The whole point of Israel was supposed to be a safe haven for
How does endless war equal safe haven? It doesn't. This isn't
about that. This is about greater Israel. And now we are enslaved
here in America saying, "Open up your wallets. Let's go. Israel
wants your money." And if you think YOU HAVE FREEDOM IN AMERICA,
YOU HAVE FREEDOM with an asterisk, except your entire government
will work for Israel. And that doesn't apply to everybody in
the Trump administration. Before Trump got neutered, he was actually
defying Israel time to time. Steve Woodcock was actually trying
to do real peace negotiations. Why do you think these things?
And then he's going to pursue further military action of course
fought by United States soldiers in Iran. I mean, the blueprint
and the plans are being drawn up for that as we speak. Please
tell me you have a source for that. And to be honest with you,
[__] one of the biggest black pills I have ever swallowed
in my life Marty is the realization that our government dollars
JSTLK,
it's your old buddy here. How many subs you need to go another
hour? All the charts are down today working late on the desk.
Uh you want me to go another hour? Uh I can do another hour.
Um
I don't know. Whatever you think's appropriate, buddy. Uh honestly,
like go nuts. It just cuz it's you. Just cuz it's you specifically,
Marty Epstein, all right? I'll go I'll go another hour.
They're supporting the bad guys. So, to summarize, the black
pill was that this government is helping Israel. None of the
other stuff, just Israel. It's always Israel. Not cutting USAID,
not blowing up our relationship with international allies. Uh
thank you very much for the 20, Marty. Appreciate it, buddy.
>> Mass arrests and deportations to C cut, not even the
fact that half the country still supports Trump in the face of
all the damage he's done that has killed and traumatized more
people between his first and second administration than Israel.
Excuse me if I find this a little disingenuous. You went to 20.
Oh, Marty with the 10 with the 10 gifted. God damn. Thank you
very much, Marty. Appreciate you, buddy.
They are stealing American resources,
Remember that time some OG dropped Jstock like $500 a stream
all night? Dude, I made like I think it was like
Yeah, I I intentionally kept upping it to make that guy stop
donating. And that guy gave I think that was like
I put hours up to like $125
or something. Or it's like $150.
And he was like, "Oh, here's four more hours." It's like, bro,
what?
I was like hours like 10 to 15 or something. American taxpayers
of the resources we Yeah, I think this is when Cherry, correct
me if I'm wrong, I think we did the low chair god stuff or some
evil fossil stuff. I started doing an accent that probably
on some platforms could get me banned.
Yeah, I think that was the evil fossil stream. I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure it was. >> desperately need in order to
aid and abet the terrorists, the terroristic regime in Israel.
I'll say the same things I've said before. Criticize Israel,
call it a settler colonial apartheid state. By itself, I can
disagree with a verbage and still recognize we can be on the
same side.
I think I think this is, by the way, real quick. I think this
is the
This is the border between Syria and Lebanon. This is the mountain
here. This this Mount Hermon right here. Um this is the guy.
So, this is supposed to be Israel, right? And they went out I
think they've basically seized or they had seized this buffer
zone so they they so that they could control Mount Hermon because
essentially if you were able to like install satellite relays
up there, you're not getting or like radar relays, you're like
never getting hit by Like the all of the enemies around them
to the north like can't do anything.
So, I think they I think they pushed in and they're probably
not going to give this up. They'll hold it the same way they've
held the Golan Heights where it's like, "Ah, you know, we're
just going to hold this and I know it's illegal, but huh. Do
something about it." With regards to the buffer zone, by the
way, the the the buffer zone that they pushed into Syria for.
Trying to achieve peace and equality, but this isn't that. It
makes those goals harder because it both expands unnecessary
action beyond what's reasonable and it obfuscates the reality.
They've enslaved the Palestinians for the last 58 years. They
say, "Oh, look, they are going to try to catch Not just in Israel,
but all over the cross the world." The Palestinians, all they
ever did was take in people that had suffered genocide and Holocaust.
They took in Armenians from the Armenian genocide. They took
in Jews from the Holocaust. >> I'm not rehashing Israel-Palestine
history. This is incorrect. Part of the problem during the Holocaust
was that immigration to mandatory Palestine was restricted to
appease the Arab population. And again, he undermines himself
with more complaints about our institution that's busy with people
of the Levant. So, the people in Washington take money from the
Israeli lobby. They're corrupt, period. There is I why is this
guy like so dead set like Israel doesn't have influence in Washington?
Israel can't control stuff?
I I don't know, man. No other reason they support Israel other
than the fact that they're crooks and they work for a different
country. And by the way, if you're allowed to murder people in
an allied country like Qatar, let alone any other country
that also means you're allowed to murder in America. Like you
think they're not going to do it? They've already Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. I reached the point where I'm like, "Okay, I'm not
uh I'm not anti-Zion enough that I'm like going to say, "Oh,
yeah, Israel's just going to kill people in America."
Not that I think they couldn't. I'm just saying I don't think
they will like willy-nilly in the way they Dude, they put their
dick on the table with Qatar. There's nobody else who did that
who could have done that strike. They just said They would never
do that in the US. Okay? That would be that would be programming
breaking. All right? They'll never risk that. >> 10 Americans
since 2022 in the West Bank and Gaza Strip. And what has our
government done? Thank you, sir. May we have another, sir? The
American citizens are useless. Who cares about them? Murder away.
No consequences, none. Sir, how much more money would you like,
sir? In reality, it's one of the worst governments that is creating
more conflict than any other government on planet Earth. Israel
is causing more conflict than any other country on
Really? Period.
I don't see North Korea attacking six of its neighbors. There
are North Korean soldiers in Ukraine, missile launches into South
Korean airspace and waters, cyberattacks and crypto scams. What
do you think their military is for? >> Israel's just creating
future terrorists. Violence begets violence. Yeah, I mean, yeah,
they're creating future terrorists, but they're also the present-day
terrorists. Can we just recognize that the motivating factors
for terrorism are not exclusively poverty or having violence
inflicted on you? This is extremely reductive. Osama bin Laden
came from a wealthy family. Ted Kaczynski was a math prodigy
and assistant professor at Berkeley. The leaders of Hamas hoarded
billions of dollars intended as aid for Palestinians in Gaza.
I don't bring this up to say that it means all the people who
would be in Hamas therefore instantly valid targets or that [__]
is even necessarily implying that. Just that the motivations
behind terrorism are ideological commitments, not just circumstances.
If we have time, I guess we'll talk about how pathetic
Hakeem Jeffries is. The next story is about how Trump used the
military to blow up a Venezuelan boat he says was trafficking
drugs, but provides no evidence about it. And a sir Okay, we
cannot
They they can't support Trump in this. They cannot they cannot
they cannot. >> is that Trump is planning a regime change
in Venezuela.
Trump is planning regime change in Venezuela. That's like obvious.
>> Um that would be yet another war that Donald Trump would
be dragging the United States military into at a time when war
is breaking out all over the Middle East because of us aiding
and abetting Israel. Because they've gone in so hard on Israel
controlling the United States, I feel obligated to point out
that America deciding to go to war with Venezuela for oil as
they imply Trump wants completely contradicts that. Either Israel
wants the United States to go to war with Iran or oil companies
want to go to war with Venezuela and our army isn't big enough
to do both. Pick >> And then of course
Wait, what? Is this guy an Asmon viewer? No, he's probably DGGR
to be honest with you. But um or like some He's like a neoliberal.
He might be like a Pisco viewer. Actually, to be honest, seems
like a LonerBox viewer if anything. Bro, did he just say that
the US can't do regime change in Venezuela and bomb Iran at the
same time? Did he just Did he just try to imply that's like impossible?
The real question is if they can do those two things while providing
arms to Ukraine and defending Taiwan from the full might of the
Chinese Navy at the same time. That's the only real question.
They with one arm tied behind their back could do regime change
in Venezuela and go to war with Iran at the same time. Absolutely.
Okay? Do you think Israel Israel's perfectly capable of decimating
Iran completely without the US's intervention anymore? The US
doesn't have to go put boots on the ground in Iran. I don't think
anybody, including these people, have ever suggested that the
US is going to put boots on the ground in Iran.
They absolutely will do regime change in Venezuela. They're explicitly
trying to do it right now.
We probably take Venezuela with like three guys flying drones.
Well, luckily, Yappasaurus Rex, you don't have to know if they
could do it minimalistically cuz they've got a whole carrier
group there, I think. I think it's a carrier group or maybe it's
just a naval base in Puerto Rico, Democratic or sorry Puerto
Rico, DR. One of the one of the two, okay?
And see you later, Azel.
they've got like 10 F-35s or 15 F-35s sitting in the region.
Like they they could do insane strikes on this country.
Right? And that's the whole thing is I think the the theory I've
seen is that they're trying to nudge some
like some kind of uprising forward and basically be like, "Listen,
if you guys if there's like a organic uprising in this country,
they might get some really
tactical air support from the United States, okay? Just some
incredibly convenient If if there happens to be like a totally
organic rise up against this government
they might get some pretty sick air support, okay? It might come
out of
Bombs falling from the sky for no >> First when it comes
to our military arsenal, there have been reports about how that
arsenal is depleted because we're of course providing weapons
to Ukraine, weapons to Israel. The list goes on and on. In what
world is this believable on its face? Uh and remember he tried
Is hold on. Is What is the >> I feel obligated to point
out that America deciding to go to war with Venezuela for oil,
as they imply Trump wants, completely contradicts that either
Israel wants the United States to go to war with Iran or oil
companies want to go to war with Venezuela and our army is in
Have they said that Israel wants the US to put boots on the ground
in Iran?
Have they Did I miss that in this video? Cuz I would say that
they think the US is is starting war with Iran by bombing
But why the
In general, we should stop talking about F-35s like they're rare,
the most abundant jet in use currently by NATO countries. Oh,
I'm not trying to say that they're I'm not trying to say that
they're rare. I'm trying to say that they're badass and they're
going to [__] that country up if they want to.
Yeah, I'm sorry. How many
How many F-22s is Venezuela rocking? The only thing that could
possibly save them, the only thing that could possibly like go
and do something right now.
I I mean, actually F-22s probably don't do anything cuz I doubt
Venezuela has any I know they have the latest Russian anti-air
or at least I believe they do. That [__] already
proven not to do [__]
The latest Russian anti-air, the latest Russian radars and anti-stealth
already got totally [__] down in Iran. It's totally
flattened. Right? Like Every country that isn't in NATO is totally
open to being like sodomized by NATO at any given moment in
That's just the fact of that's the facts of the world right now.
big enough to do both. Pick one. >> And then of course,
when it comes to our military arsenal, there's been reports about
how that arse Lots of countries are about to change that though.
How? Where? How?
What What evidence is there of any radar array that's that's
actually detecting stealth at the level of the F-35 at this
The Gripen. Wait, the Gripen isn't the Chinese one, is it?
And I hope you're not just talking about Oh, no, this is a This
is not the Chinese one.
Wait, how would this help?
You what?
Oh, you're responding to somebody else. Oh, oh, the Gripen. Oh,
the Gripen's like the Kmart fighter jet that Sweden's selling
to the world. Like the the one that's like kind of a I Yeah,
I remember. snows depleted because we're Bro, I'm sitting here
like, dude, the I couldn't see the
I actually agree with their statement, but it's not what the
other chatter's talking about. I got a crazy video. Okay. Of
course, providing weapons to Ukraine, weapons to Israel. The
list goes on and on. And what world is this believable on its
face? Oh, and remember he tried to start a war with Venezuela
last time he was president. Then why did you think he would cut
defense spending after the election? Establishment 101.
Neocon 101.
More normalizing language that this is just what Republicans
and Neocons do. This is an epic disaster. This is an Ameri I
mean, it is what Neocons do. This is literally what Neocons do.
Where's Where's the confusion with the
Where Yeah, we're manufacturing some impetus for war to get oil
from another country, to to lock down oil for some of our corporations.
This is literally just one to one with what Cheney did in Iraq,
It's the exact How is it any different?
Uh what's wrong with this video though? It is just showing TYT
throws Oh, I I'm just laughing because it's um It's just funny
watching somebody go through the like Willy Mac talking points
on a bunch of different things,
Uh Hasan video, the Mike from PA video, the Anarchist Bernie
video.
I'm just I'm laughing the whole time and just enjoying it. Honestly
though, I will give them This video is way better. This video
is like way way way way better than the the Hasan one. The Hasan
one was kind of rough. This one? Yeah, it turns out Cenk and
Ana say some >> This is ugliness done on behalf of Well,
that was yet another piece of evidence that this is the kayfabe
presidency. The wrestling theater. Uh is Venezuela the largest
exporter of drugs in the region? Not even close. So, look, I
don't want to give them ideas about Mexico or Colombia, but uh
does Colombia export more drugs than Venezuela? Yes. Oh my god,
it's about immigration. Crime in Venezuela sends people seeking
asylum and refuge to America and the people in America then hear
about Venezuelan immigrants taking over Colorado high-rises that
you reported on. Venezuela doesn't need to export the most drugs,
they just need to be seen as the most prominent country causing
the immigration crisis. It ain't about drugs, it's about oil.
What? I thought
I thought it was Is that That might be true. Listen, I don't
know enough to dispute that. I know there is some concern about
crime in Venezuela supporting like floods of the American border,
but I don't I don't think that's like the narrative that the
Trump regime is is running with, right? The Trump regime is running
with a narrative of these are narco-terrorists
who run drugs into our country and poison our country,
Like I I'm pretty confident the drug is like the entirety of
their messaging right now. So, there's no question about that.
I can't believe our Secretary of Defense is a weekend Fox host.
Agreed. Like this is a joke, man. It's especially sickening,
guys, cuz they constantly use our troops as sitting ducks. They
put them in the middle of the Middle East. Oh, please Iran attack
them, please, so we can wipe out the Iranian regime and do a
regime change like Israel ordered us to. Believe it or not, Iran
isn't dumb enough to do that, so we're not stupid enough to offer
the opportunity. The last time Iran struck the US military under
Trump, we notably did not do any regime change for Israel. And
then we go to Brian Kilmeade saying he wants to
Wait, that's because
that's because Iran called the US up and was like, "Hey,
we're going to strike you. Please, please, please, for the love
of God, please move anything that could Please, for the love
of God, we're going to hit right here. We're going to hit right
here. Please, for the love of God, do not have any people right
there, please.
We want We need to save face. Please don't have any people where
we're going to hit you, please."
That's like the phone call from Iran to the United States. Yeah.
Yeah, Cenk's obviously hyperbolic on the Israel stuff. I mean,
yeah, he's he's obviously hyperbolic on the Israel stuff. US
military under Trump, we notably did not do any regime change
for Israel. And then we go to Brian Kilmeade saying he wants
to euthanize the homeless. He apologized.
I would say also from what I remember, there's actual reports
around the time that Israel was really hitting Iran hard that
Israel did have a window where they could have taken out um al-Khamenei.
Khamenei, right? They could have taken out the the supreme ruler
of Iran. And I think the US said, "No, no, no, no, no, no, don't
do that." DON'T CARE. HE still sucks. Cenk brings up someone
homeless that he helped out. That's genuinely nice. I'm glad
he did that. >> I've got a loved one who had schizophrenia.
And by the way, he's better now. Ryan, we didn't have to keep
And lastly, we have the Cenk interview. >> I got a fever.
And the only prescription is Cenk rhetorical. All right. All
right.
I'm just going to invade. I don't think they Hold on. I I haven't
heard them say they say do regime change in Iran. They've never
said boots on the ground in Iran. Why would they have to Why
would they have to invade to do regime change? I I don't see
why they'd have to invade somewhere to do regime change. Action.
All right, guys. So, I'm going to tell you about how Tucker Carlson
is trying to get every other Okay, hold on. This video, if you're
into this sort of thing, it's only a matter of time before this
kind of technology becomes widespread outside of NATO because
it's all software and doesn't require special sensors.
Oh, is this the thing Elon Musk was referring to? demonstrating
a brand new technique I made for asteroid detection, which is
so powerful that even though the demo is only using free $30
webcams, it is still able to vastly outperform
Oh, this is the low-light cameras, right? This is the low-light
cameras tracking uh This is I feel like Elon Musk referred to
this. He's like, "Oh, F-35s are outdone by like low-light cameras.
Um like cheap low-light cameras, they're not going to matter
anymore.
Right? It's all about drone swarms. Isn't this this Elon Musk
suggested that this is the way to deal with F-35s, right? Oh,
we can check this out at some point. Be interesting. reporters
not talk about the good economy. This video is sponsored by aspiration.com/tyt.
Tucker went on air Friday night to bully Jim Cramer from CNBC.
Cramer said one of a rare honest thing. So, obviously uh Tucker
Carlson's furious about that. So, he said this is the best economy
he's ever seen. Unemployment claims are at a 52-year low. But
the rest of mainstream media totally followed and has actually
doubled down and poured fuel all over that fire is they took
a really hot economy and said it's a really bad thing. And you
don't want to give credit to a good economy because they actually
passed bills that helped American voters. Oh, that coronavirus
relief bill mainly went to you guys. So, Tucker Carlson comes
in and he's going to bully him because he doesn't want any other
reporters saying the thing that is true. Part of how Fox News
drives the agenda. So, he knows that if he says outrageous and
awful things about Jim Cramer, um everybody will hear it and
report it cuz they'll be shocked and shriek like, "Oh, no, that
is There's terrible Tucker Carlson attacking us again." To get
the media attention that he wants, right? But he's getting that
attention to direct it towards what? To direct it towards you
better not say anywhere on television that the economy is doing
well. Now, can he bully the rest of the media that way? Of course.
Of course, he can.
He did the lie. He did the lie.
Tonight, I'll also be on NewsNation with Chris Cuomo debating
the Israel issue, is it a genocide or not? I'm also going to
do a special live show with
Tucker Carlson. That seemed really hard to get out. I wonder
why. And I can just sort of picture the scene in a lamp-lit room
with a bunch of guys sitting around eating hummus thinking about,
"What do we do about this guy telling the truth about us? We
must make him stop talking." First thing out the gate, the UN
Commission on Gaza
Dude, Tucker was pretty out of pocket for this, okay?
This was kind of a wild one from Tucker.
Tucker Carl These These people in Israel sitting around eating
hummus talking about how we got to kill the truth tellers. That
seemed really hard to get out. I wonder why. >> And I can
just sort of picture the scene in a lamp-lit room with a bunch
of guys sitting around thinking
about, about this guy telling the truth about us? WE MUST MAKE
HIM STOP TALKING." FIRST thing out the gate, the UN Commission
on Gaza has come out and said that Israel is committing a genocide
in their report. Commission had actually put out a report earlier
that found Israel had committed war crimes against humanity.
I've got my own issues with the report, but none are substantive
enough at the moment to call out in any meaningful way. I'm sure
there are people on YouTube who will go into more detail with
research if you're curious, but for our purposes, let's just
accept their determination. Okay, how funny is
This is like a weird aside. How funny is it that this guy copies
LonerBox, and then he's got no opinion on the thing that LonerBox
didn't cover, according to you guys?
That seems like a weird That seems like a weird
I don't know. I think You better not call it a genocide. Well,
they did anyway. The only three groups left on Israel's side
is Israel's hard right wing. Then the second group is Western
leaders, and the third group is Western media. Can a country,
just with controlling Western leaders and media, be able to pull
off a genocide and totally get away with it? >> If it's
just money, Israel isn't the richest country in the world. It's
not even the richest country in the region. You don't have to
do this whole song and dance. If America's government is for
sale, why is Israel the only one who seems to be trying to buy
it? >> Can we get the entire world to shut up and follow
our orders?
I mean, does he want to know the actual answer to that question?
Cuz the answer to that question is
going to be considered like deeply anti-Semitic. It would have
to do with the special relationship between America and Israel,
the hyper success of Israeli billionaires in the US, and their
willingness to lobby and spend their money as US Israeli dual
citizens on lobbying in favor of Israel in a way that circumvents
in like uh what do you call it? Like foreign
Right? Because they are technically dual
In a way that happens for no other
Like to any similar extent.
But like that when you do that dual loyalty argument, everybody's
going to accuse you of being anti-Semitic. That's how it is,
right? And I don't think that doesn't give you like full control
over everything. That's not it at all, but it like nudges things,
for sure. Don't hate Israelis, though. Don't hate the Israeli
government. Don't hate the Israeli government. Don't hate the
IDF. Another interesting slip. >> It's a live-streamed
genocide.
But don't speak out about it. >> all those jokes about
right-wing media pundits saying that they're being silenced in
the books they're busy promoting on big media tours? I was just
thinking about that for no reason. They're literally on the side
of being >> A quick word about calling people pro-genocide.
It's a vacuous accusation. Like they brought this back around
to Bush. It's the exact same you want the terrorists to win argument
we heard in the mid-2000s. It's an insult intended to shut down
argument that isn't even reserved for the people who say, "Actually,
I like the IDF." All these people. You would be considered pro-genocide
for thinking the IDF isn't doing a good job.
Sounds less less anti-Semitic if you say that they're symbiotic
with the world. I mean, that That basically No, it it doesn't.
Chris, that that is placing them outside of humanity as a different
entity that is beneficial, but like not the same. I don't think
I don't think people consider that less anti-Semitic. I think
that's actually more >> Uh Netanyahu has to have a No,
they're like totally They're like weird genetic freaks that aren't
really human, but they do help in their own way. >> The
conflicts of interest to effectively prosecute this war. The
war crimes themselves are unconscionable. Withholding aid is
genocidal, but it's has been an ineffective and tyrannical government,
and they do need to be deposed militarily if they can't be removed
democratically. Like, what is the actual position here if your
main cause is Israel bad and not Palestinians good? Because it's
certainly not the fighting needs to stop. It's the fighting has
made me upset, and to me at least, that's the most selfish position
you can have about this war, prioritizing your feelings over
someone else's survival. Cenk calls Kash Patel's response to
Senate questioning Israeli. Uh they sound Israeli. Not because
Epstein is related to Israel, except for all the times he strongly
implied that he is. It's Israeli because it's obviously a lie.
I mean, they sound so absurd in their denial that it sounds like
the Israeli government. You're saying, "Oh yeah, I'm being just
like all the other admin That's I'm sorry.
I feel like this reputation's earned, man. I I do.
Maybe I could be convinced otherwise, but I feel like this reputation
for Israel, for the government of Israel, is earned at this point.
For For like 2 years, we've been going, "Hey, man, I think that's
that's like enough, right? Hey, like you got you've You're like
10x their kill count. Like, is that That's probably enough, right?
Hey, you're like 20x their kill count. Could you like chill now?
Hey, you're like 30, 40, 50x their kill count. Could you chill?
Right? And the whole Every time they're like, "Listen, we we
are not safe. We are not safe. It's not over yet. We're not safe."
Oh, you just totally like sci-op'd this entire military group
in Lebanon into carrying pagers that will explode in their pockets,
and all of their leadership is dead. It looks like you're basically
smurfing as grandmaster players of some video game in like the
silver bracket. You're just destroying You're completely wiping
these people out. Okay, it's like kind of gross now. Like, can
you stop? Can you stop killing them all? Oh, you're going to
kill more. Okay. Uh you're going to set up like like like areas
where these starving people can go get food, and then you're
going to just gun them down. Okay, cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool.
Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. >> ministrations, just like our
beloved Like I'm I'm sorry, at this point it's like I don't I
don't want to I don't trust you. What do you think the kill count
is in Gaza currently? Uh I don't know. Between 65 and 150k?
Somewhere in there? I'm guessing the numbers vary greatly. Biden
or beloved Obama. Just
the open-endedness of this stuff is what lends itself towards
conspiratorial thinking. Not that these pieces of information
don't come together in a pattern of egregious behavior to protect
Epstein clients, but that framing it with why allows people to
fill in their own answers to connect the dots. But something
happened following Benjamin Netanyahu's visit to the United States,
his meeting with Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. I don't think
it lets them fill in their own answers. When you tell them why,
and you say it's Israel, I I think you're filling in your own
answer, no?
You're literally filling I'm telling you what the answer is.
The reason why all of these get away is because of Israel. That's
I mean, that's what they're doing. If Donald Trump Donald Trump
changed As the news media, it's your responsibility to frame
things in a clear and concise way to provide cause and effect
so that speculation doesn't get out of control. Yeah. What is
Trump hiding? Yeah, well, he's definitely hiding something. Uh
I and I I genuinely don't know if he was a client or not, but
You genuinely don't know. All the criticism of Kash Patel denying
an Epstein list, and you don't know if Trump would be on it.
I mean, this is all like 1984 level uh propaganda. I mean, George
Orwell was genius of geniuses. >> That's not 1984 propaganda.
>> The former prime minister of Israel. The list goes on
and on.
Match that with the deaths from Ukraine and Russia. Um aren't
the numbers like way lower? Aren't the like overall populations
like totally, completely, and entirely different?
Like, what's the population of Gaza with 150,000 dead? Wouldn't
that be like crazy? Like a crazy massive difference. >> on.
That Or is that your point, full of it? It's actually true. He's
talking about Ehud Barak, prime minister in 1999. The country's
starting to get united on this issue, Epstein files. Maybe we
can build off of it, maybe we can't build off of it. They think
it's a Jewish conspiracy. You think it's an Israeli conspiracy.
I'm not sure I'm comfortable with that kind of unity. Uh if the
Israelis ever hold uh Netanyahu accountable, it'll be a great
day in world history. I wouldn't hold your breath. Uh that's
true. We should all come together and agree that it's an Israeli
conspiracy.
And comedy is something the entire world loves, okay? Those two
things. >> That's But it's not impossible.
help them? Like, you've just presented a clear through-line to
end the genocide, dissolve the Likud government, get the people
on your side. Your entire thing has been about open debate. So,
try to convince them. You put more faith in MAGA to become liberal
based on Epstein than you do Israelis to vote out Netanyahu.
When you hear commentary from the right about how they, Charlie
Kirk, what does they mean? It means the left or the Jews. Usually
both. >> One of the things that I asked before we found
out what his vote was. I mean, it just It means the left in that
case. I I'm pretty sure when they're saying they in the Charlie
Kirk case, that's the left, okay? There are conspiratorial people,
but they're far outside the majority. The majority of people
are going, "Hey, lefties. You need to be scared." was or were
is if it's the Groypers, should we hate all of them, and should
we attack them, and generalize about them? If it turns out it's
the opposite, it's the left, should we hate them and attack them?
And then you when you ask that question, you begin to realize
how absurd it is. It's one person, and that's kind of obvious
once you think it through. You don't need Charlie Kirk's murder
to hate Groypers. Terrorism is always the dumbest thing in the
world. It's like
I I know that. Why does Why is he saying that when he's been
comparing these guys to Nick Fuentes the whole time? It hasn't
worked since 1948. >> Oh my god, he's talking about the
founding of Israel. Among the conservatives who called out Bondi
was Eric Erickson, who I think is actually been a pretty reasonable
member on the >> Marxist ideology insists that men are
men and women are women. >> I'm sure I disagree with him
on a whole host of things, but he seems to have some actual moral
values. He seems Why Wait. Why did he pick the Those are cringe
virtue-signaling points, but like
why did Why did he pick those points as like the most objectionable
opinions from that these days. >> about this country. President
Trump makes comments like that. It Uh I just believe that there's
two genders. Two genders, okay? If you don't believe that there's
two genders, then you don't like reality. You don't like me.
And I want you to let that ruminate. communicates to me that
he doesn't care about our
I meant marinate there. I was trying to do He doesn't care about
what makes this country great. >> I'm sorry. Every time
I hear a criticism of Donald Trump at this point, it's like that
knee-reflex test you get at a doctor's office where I just go,
"So, why didn't you vote for Harris?" You did not vote for Donald
Trump. You did not vote for Kamala Harris. Correct?
>> If she gets her way, every administration's going to
change it. So, when you've got a Republican in charge, it's going
to be hate against uh right-wing individuals. When Democrats
get in charge, no, that's not hate anymore. Now hate is racism,
sexism, etc. What is this argument? Like, I agree that hate speech
shouldn't be banned for the greater harm that government restrictions
on speech can impose, but Cenk's example is that Dems would say
that racism is bad, and Republicans would say that racism is
good. All right. So, then that leads to how did the right wing
react? We said we were against hate speech being classified as
a crime. We're still against it even when we were in charge.
And I got to tell you, you got to give them credit for that.
>> Oh, Cenk. I really don't. I I I told you it's going
to be this guy's going to soy so hard about Ted Cruz, and the
the props they're going to give Ted Cruz cuz they're trying to
be bipartisan. They're trying to reach across the aisle and be
nice to people who like do the good behaviors.
When you say principled even when you're in charge, I mean, we
were so worried that they were not going to stick to principles.
They were just going to go for raw power. What? >> What?
What? For them to say no to Pam Bondi, no to Trump on this, that's
pretty That's pretty great, guys. No, it's not. It's really not.
They push back because they know they don't have to actually
do anything. They can just continue to support Trump, who in
turn will do it anyway. Now we learn what Ana and Cenk's names
mean. Keeper of treasure? Ooh. Which, you know. Sorry.
I take not sorry. That's okay. All >> And as you a lot
of you know that have been with us for a while, Cenk means war.
After that, we go into Cenk's appearance on Piers Morgan opposite
former TYT associate, Russian stooge, and soulless husk, Dave
Rubin. Do you think Charlie wanted to be martyred? Oh, I I Hold
on. Listen, former TYT associate, Russian stooge, and soulless
husk, Dave
honestly 100% thought and misunderstood I thought he was just
going to refer to Constantine there. TYT associate, soulless
husk husk, and what was the other one? After that, we go into
Cenk's appearance on Piers Morgan opposite former TYT associate,
Russian stooge, and soulless husk. Russian stooge, yeah. Russian
stooge, soulless husk, and former TYT associate. I guess not
former, current TYT associate, Konstantin Kissin. Absolute
>> Dave Rubin. Do you think Charlie wanted to be martyred?
Do you think Charlie wanted to be martyred? Do you think Charlie
wanted to be killed? Yes or no?
Of course not. What kind of ass-backwards question is that? Hey
Cenk, Dave Rubin's like a total loser, have you thought about
that? Maybe you should stop saying Ted Cruz was right to denounce
Donald Pam Bondi or Donald Trump's move to put in hate speech
laws. Maybe you should do that. Maybe you should just you know,
hate him. >> Times has uncovered some of these shady business
deals involving his family and his Middle East envoy, Steve Witkoff.
>> If you're wondering whether Cenk has anything to say
about Witkoff when yesterday he said that he was really trying
for Middle East peace. He does not. >> I'm tired of Donald
Trump suing the press every time they hurt his bad feelings.
I'm a smear Uh Constantine's associate? Well, I assume they don't
mean like on the air like correspondent.
Um maybe they I mean that's probably actually that is probably
what he meant, but I was just like, oh associate, I didn't draw
that same comparison in my >> by the New York Times. This
is not about defending them. This is about defending the press.
But make no mistake about it, this law Who's Dave? Yeah, Dave
was. I think Dave's there for the 2016 coverage, right? You guys
know the video I'm talking about?
The Young Turks meltdown coverage from
Dave Rubin's there for this, isn't he? in conversation with that
Aiyerola Of course. I could have sworn he he swaps in at some
point. >> big Actually, so what I mean is show me
Is Dave not here at any point? He don't >> Dave swung by.
He bribed Paul. God damn it. I'm wrong. I don't think I'm wrong.
I'm wrong.
I could have sworn Dave swung by for some point here or at some
point.
Doesn't look like it though. Who's sitting in the chairs off
to the side?
Nope, he wasn't here for this. Man, how did I hallucinate that?
Uh Ru- Rubin used to be one of their like very close associates
though. Rubin used to be on that show.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Rubin used to be on >> lawsuit that Trump
is filing against the New York Times is meant to intimidate them
and prevent them from reporting on what he might be doing in
in the Oval Office, what actions he might be engaging in that
could be illegal or unethical. I hope they fight back. >> what?
Good enough. I call their coverage of this story decent reporting.
So and remember, it's even if you love
the president isn't always going to be Trump. So next time a
Democrat's in charge, oh, where did they get the crypto money
from? Israel or Saudi Arabia or China or North Korea or Exxon
Mobil or Bob? I retract my previous
Wait. Isn't that like a valid question?
Like, oh, they're supporting a bunch of technologies that will
would have basically allowed them to take like totally laundered
money and Trump's enriching himself this way and he could easily
be making decisions on behalf of foreign countries just based
on the checks he's getting I think that's a valid concern. It's
a valid like thing to express.
I don't know if it I'd quite do it that way, but hey. So I've
given this advice to Democrats and President Obama many times
before, they never listen. Never agree with a Republican, they
will only use it against you. During the election, intelligence
agencies come to President Obama and they say the Russians are
trying to interfere in the election. It looks like they want
to cause chaos. They're also against Hillary Clinton and it appears
they're in favor of Donald Trump. So what does Obama do? Instead
of going out and telling everybody about that, he does what is
the responsible thing to do. He calls in congressional leaders
including Republicans and Mitch McConnell says, "Nothing. Don't
you dare say that in public. If you say it, we'll say you're
rigging the election in favor of Hillary Clinton." So Obama being
of course who he is, he's like, "Okay, okay, I won't say it.
I won't say it." So why do I bring it up today? Because Donald
Trump in his weird White House lawn discussion yesterday with
the press, when asked about Russian collusion, said, "Oh no,
it's not me. It's Obama." In other words, because Obama listened
to the Republicans and agreed with the Republicans not to tell
the American people before the election that Russia was trying
to help Trump. Trump now turns around and blames >> Okay,
listen. I take no responsibility for Cenk doing his like Kyle
Kulinski
Peter Zeihan outdoor videos, okay? Whatever he says outside in
the light of the sun, I take no responsibility >> Obama
the fool, never agree with a Republican. They will always use
it against you. So Democrats, for God's sake, stop trying to
look for stupid bipartisan compromises. The Republicans are I
think this guy's doing a way better job at this video. All of
the cuts in between are trying to show like when TYT was based
and they had like the right
When they were like, oh, you can't ever negotiate with these
people, these people are always like evil. So he's like, oh,
I really like this. It's This is like
other than, okay, what was the first one? The Ryan Grim tweets,
that made no [__] sense. I feel like there've been
a other a couple other points that don't make sense, but this
one is so much more coherent than the previous video. >> They're
not interested in compromises. How about instead of the opposite
party, you fight them instead? What's wrong with with recording
outside? Eh. We're over the hump, 2 days left. Hopefully the
next couple of days are easy. So joining us now is Ken Klippenstein.
Oh, [__] my I always love the fact that you're willing
to publish things that other journalists or reporters are Wait,
what is this guy's problem with Ken Klippenstein? Ken Klippenstein's
like the most libbed up dude on the planet of Earth.
What? for whatever reason terrified to publish. Yeah, Ken Klippenstein's
Substack is super edgy. If you also believe yogurt is too spicy.
Oh, I'm saying it. The conversation starts out mostly fine talking
about how the shooter was just an ordinary guy. >> The whole
thing just fell apart. >> But when they get to broader
politics The whole thing just fell apart. How often do you see
Chuck Schumer getting up there and saying Donald Trump is just
such an existential threat? When I see something like that, I
think, okay, what is he not saying? He's not talking about all
the policy stuff. You have both sides and Chuck Schumer saying
Trump is an existential threat and Trump using the military to
blow up a Venezuelan boat, which Cenk and Ana talked about yesterday
as a pretense for invading Venezuela. Um I see it as a cop Wait,
he literally is using it for a pretense as a pretense for regime
change in Venezuela. This guy keeps confusing like regime change
with boots on the ground invasions.
And I just don't think I don't think he understands the difference.
Or maybe Ken just says invasion and he's way too I will say they've
got a lot of um They for some reason they have a lot of like
infrastructure or boats that can be used to transport marines
onto the ground, like onto dry land off of the
I don't know why they have I think they have one or two of those
boats that do like 500 marines a boat and they just they're like
for amphibious assaults. pop out a lot of ways and useful to
them to just like rash up rhetoric sound like, "Look, I'm doing
all this really exciting stuff." Trump too, when he does these
when he when he blows up the boat. And so since he's not actually
going to fix that in a systemic way, you've got to create this
theater of look how tough I'm being just like I was talking about
with with
the Democrats. Don't get upset at the person doing bad stuff.
Get upset at the people calling it out for saying that it's bad.
Just ringing the alarm all the time and and and some people are
going to take that seriously. I mean that's the reason why I
see this as like the kayfabe like presidency. Nothing's really
real, but it's exciting and it seems like something real was
happening. This isn't some profound understanding. This was happening
during his first administration. Would you say the killing of
Iranian General Soleimani was just kayfabe? There are dead people
on a boat who you yourself said have not been identified nor
confirmed as having committed any crime extrajudicially in international
waters and you're comparing that to Chuck Schumer saying that's
an emergency in terms of there not being an actual emergency.
This is the kind
I think he's So maybe I'm misunderstanding. It seemed like he
was saying, "Well, nobody's going to fix this in a in an existential
or sorry, systemic way." Right? Nobody's going to fix the drug
running problem the drug problem in the United States in a in
a systematic way. So or systematic way. So they're going to do
this thing where they're going like, "Oh, look at this the drug
dealers. We're like literally just killing the drug dealers.
Here's Here's videos of us the drug dealers, arresting criminals.
Look at us clear out this MS-13 drug den. Look at these sick
drone videos of us sending prisoners back to C cot." Right? That's
like, oh, but they're not doing like substantial fixes to border
policy maybe. Like I think that's more the direction Ken's heading
in.
I think I think that's what he's saying. Were there real drug
dealers? I think there were possibly real drug dealers, but there's
definitely like a Colombian boat that got shot down now. They
could definitely do it, evil Johnny Bravo. Like I I think
I feel like Venezuela's got nothing on the US. I feel like the
US people don't understand how far the US is, okay? The US is
like
I don't know. The US has been operating on like a thousand science
for like 50 years and Venezuela's been operating on like a hundred
science, okay? Like it's it's the civ game is it's totally unbalanced,
it's totally out of
And America's just got like logistics infrastructure on their
side that they could do this kind of thing. They could totally
I think they could actually do it. Like an actual
Yeah, we're
Listen, we're going to have lunch in Caracas, okay? >> kind
of stuff that makes me bristle when I talk about Casa because
in every other circumstance they show that they do not care about
people getting killed. If it proves they can seem above it all.
Look at the National Guard deployments. I I oppose those and
I think that's bad just because it's corrosive to democratic
attitudes to just see troops marching out. That being said, they're
not going to do anything. This is a show. I oppose it because
it's doing something, not because it'll do something except for
all the stuff it's doing. They don't have the rules of engagement,
they don't have authority to shoot someone. Many of the people
I talked to they're like, "I'm not going to do that even if they
tell me to." Oh, so it's harmless then because you were able
to confirm that anecdotally that it
I don't I think he opposes
Doesn't Ken like oppose all of these things? He's saying that
like I don't think they're going to like do a crackdown where
they try to like take over and like, you know, overthrow like
some election or so something in like one of these cities. I
don't think they're doing that, but like obviously it's still
really bad. It's it's like
all for optics. I don't even think this is like a bad opinion.
It's like it's
I don't I don't think he's trying to say it's like not important.
He's trying to say that people aren't focused on
They're focused on like the Trump moving the like the the Trump
shell game of him moving the focus from >> the situation
out of the soldier's control when they're holding a weapon. No
mistakes will be made and no orders will be given that actually
create the pressure they need to resist as opposed to just talking
about it. I am glad you thought this through and come to this
conclusion. Beautiful. The Democrats look at that and they say,
"Okay, look, it's a military coup is coming. They're going to
overthrow the country." Very convenient for them cuz then they
don't have to deliver on anything. They don't need to have any
actual policy concessions. They can just say, "Look how scary
the other side is." Remember that time they actually tried that
and it was quite inconvenient for them as well and and like I
said before corrosive to democratic culture. Stop saying corrosive
to democracy as though that isn't extremely bad by itself. Everyone
benefits except the public.
Oh, I didn't know that Evil Morty that they're the part of like
a a strike group? I should have known that cuz I think they sent
them to Israel as well.
I should have known that cuz there was a strike group that moved
close to Israel and people were talking about how it could move
Marines onto the People were scared about boots on the ground.
So, I'm surprised I didn't hear that same point back then. Kens
doing here by calling Trump's actions impotent isn't actually
a criticism. He's telling people on the left that their worries
about it are overblown. Calling the National Guard kayfabe as
though mobilizing thousands of people with guns didn't in itself
an extremely serious action makes it harder to rightfully call
it out as an overreach intended to suppress suppress democratic
state resistance even if he's also doing it to put on a show
for the red states that support him. Like a boxing match is a
show, but that doesn't make a punch after the bell okay just
because you should be expecting to get hit. And like what what
Trump is doing is wrong, obviously. I disagree with what he's
doing with deploying the National Guard as well, but the way
the way that it's um marketed by Democrats How should one market
the president sending the National Guard into a city where they're
not needed in a state where they're not wanted for a crime problem
that doesn't exist entirely as a show of force for their own
base that ratchets up the temperature for violence that you say
you wanted to bring down because of its ability to encourage
someone to take matters into their own hands. Anything for that.
Now Anna praises Thomas Massie for his handling of the Epstein
files in a hearing with Kash Patel. It seems like he's really
acting on his principles with regards to need to protect women
from dangerous predators except for that time he voted against
reauthorizing the Prevent Violence Against Women Act. >> We
got to give Massie credit for calling Kash Patel out for the
lie that he told when he was testifying before I mean, I dude,
I don't know. I feel like you could just say these acts are good.
Is saying that like somebody did something good, is that really
equivalent to like both sidesing an
I feel like there should be some way to elucidate that, right?
I could say Ted Cruz's response to the FCC stuff the FCC stuff
with regards to Jimmy Kimmel was good. I don't have to say I
like Ted Cruz. I don't say I have to say I support Ted Cruz or
that Republicans are
But like saying a good thing is good should be good? Telling
the truth should be good? I don't know. >> for the Senate
Judiciary Committee just yesterday. We used to have more sophisticated
liars in the administration. Deciding where you land on political
policy depending on like political labels is a good way of promoting
things that might actually be destructive for your life. You
know what I'm saying? I do not. You know, I I That's why at this
point I look at both parties and I'm like, "Listen, I'm just
going to judge on an on an issue by issue basis and You're saying
this immediately after covering how the
is completely stupid even for her. >> is covering for because
one of them said they were upset while remaining in that party.
In terms of political lead, I think that, you know, both sides
have really failed ordinary Americans. Who is the guy just
You know, the only way that Trump can really carry out a coup
is if he gets the military to back it and There's like there's
something going on here where
Republicans are like evil, but Democrats are incompetent and
you should probably be able to criticize the Democrat incompetence
without
other people feeling like you're equating it to the Republican
like evil, the actual
like borderline evil they're they're going with, right?
Cuz it like I'm sorry, but all the stuff in the DOJ, that's
And you have to be able to say that that's totally different
from anything the Democrats are doing, but the Democrats are
sort of like impotent and not effective in any way.
Doesn't mean they'll vote for them, but like Jesus, could they
figure something out? And I don't think that they would. I could
be wrong, but I doubt it. Obligatory Israel coverage this time
about soldiers needing more help from the government to manage
the psychological distress and trauma they endured from their
service. You're watching Israeli soldiers dump piles of psychiatric
medications on the table during a Knesset subcommittee meeting
on mental health because it was never about getting the hostages
back. A political project that Netanyahu has always wanted, which
is this expansionist Greater Israel policy, and it also allows
him to remain in power at a time when he's facing serious corruption
charges. That's who Netanyahu is. Before we move on from that,
Anna alludes to October 7th being an inside job. serious examples
in recent years where he was critical of, you know, some of what
the Israeli government was up to. Uh
Is this talking about There's no way this is talking about Charlie
Kirk, right? This is just talking Her's talking about how Charlie
Kirk said this about Netanyahu. after October 7th, uh he went
on the PBD podcast and kind of questioned whether the government
allowed it to happen, whether there were stand down orders and
now we have some IDF testimony where they're claiming that they
were told to stand down. I'm not willing to cut Cenk any slack
at this point that he's Wait, does she does he realize that he
just blamed Anna for just quoting Charlie Kirk?
Like she just relayed what Charlie Kirk said on the PBD podcast.
And then he's like this is like conspiring about Israel. She's
saying October 7th was an inside job. No, she's saying Charlie
said Octo- something was [__] with October 7th. >> is unaware
of who Candace Owens is or what she has been saying about Charlie
Kirk. Please check out Candace Owens on the Charlie Kirk issue.
She does some solid deep dives. Uh Disrupt Daily uh says Tucker
says some really nice things about Cenk. I don't know who specifically
came out and said that BB Charlie Kirk, but now that he's for
the second time denying that he is, people are going, "What's
actually going on here?" You're not making people feel comfortable
with the fact that you keep coming out to have to deny something
that certainly wasn't asserted by me on this program. Am I lying?
So, the fact that he brushes past that comment is be better,
man. Then Anna plays a clip of Benny Johnson talking to himself
in the future as a lead-in to Jimmy Kimmel getting pulled off
the air after making a joke about Kirk's assassination. Cenk
thinks that it was bad to pull him. And then my guess is Kimmel
would go, "Oh, you're right. I get it. We shouldn't have done
that, right?" >> I disagree with you. Anna thinks there's
some legitimacy due to what Kimmel said making the right upset.
Put your shoes in the shoes of conservatives. Maybe Put your
shoes in the shoes. >> There's a world where that makes
sense, but it's not one where the outrage being generated was
preemptively manufactured. The right has not shown any kind of
good faith even about Charlie Kirk's murder and there's no reason
to think that that Is he just going to talk over Anna instead
of letting her I don't remember what Anna said after this. I
think it
But he's like, "Aren't you making a point about this?" believing
that manufactured anger will do anything but enable even more
manufactured anger. Then they look at new polling which suggests
the youth likes Put your shoes in their shoes. Put your shoes
in their shoes.
And then he just cut her off. I think man, I remember I watched
that clip on stream. I don't remember exactly where she goes
with that.
She's saying like something it was stupid. But why was it stupid?
socialism more than capitalism. What is a youth? Excuse me, Yianni.
Youths. And a distaste for what a capitalistic society has led
to. Giant wealth inequality, unaffordable housing, all sorts
of issues that Democrats are blaming on Hey, the problems we
are experiencing are not inherent to capitalism and can still
exist under socialism. People will push the limits of what they
can get away with to gain any kind of advantage for themselves.
A socialist society does not inherently do anything to fix that
and if anything makes it harder to fix. That's something to wrestle
with in how it's implemented. To say that capitalism as a system
in itself is inherently the cause of these issues shifts the
blame and therefore makes finding solutions difficult because
any kind of improvement that doesn't dissolve capitalism becomes
seen as ineffective. No, what's wrong, guys, is money in politics.
Surely we're all against corporatism cuz it attacks all of us.
I I agree for the most part. I'm just I'm I'm reading. Give me
a second. Yeah, this one this one was brutal. This day was like
pretty brutal. I don't think that's like super criticizable coverage
from them. Other than I guess whatever Anna said that got cut
off
if I remember correctly.
And now? Read it out loud. Dude, I'm I'm EP. Cenk clip inside
talk to Kirk shooter's friends. Trump want only calling the wantonly
Sorry, Trump
God, I know the word want. I use it all the time. Trump wantonly
calling the National Guard is an issue, question mark? I don't
I don't think that's what Kimmel was saying. He was saying the
issue is different than what you think.
Thomas Massie grilled Kash Patel on Epstein files. That makes
up for all awful things he voted for, I guess. No, and nobody
suggested that? Former IDF soldiers aren't getting help they
need from the government. Who cares? They're
Don't even remember Don't even remember their response to that,
to be honest.
Tucker Carlson defends Charlie Kirk from Netanyahu. I guess that
makes Tucker Carlson good?
I Was that said?
Maybe that was said. Uh let's see here. ABC suspends Jimmy Kimmel.
I guess Kimmel shouldn't have hurt the conservative feelings
conservatives feelings if he wants to have a show. Man, I really
remember thinking Anna sounded stupid with what she said in response
to that with the 10 uh I was going to say 10 shoes down cuz somebody
said it in chat. It's madic or
Um but no, no, no, no. Private Huff said it. Um I the clip where
she's like, "Oh, put your shoes in their shoes." That one I think
was I remember being baffled. I remember being baffled on that
one.
And now? Weird [__] explain that's had me spiraling
since I started watching The Young Turks. Why does their website
still sell merchandise that promotes social distancing and hand
washing? Do they have the likeness rights to Rosa Parks, Ketanji
Brown Jackson, AOC, Ilhan Omar, Rashida Tlaib, and Ayanna Pressley
to be selling shirts with their likeness according to the descriptions?
Are some of the designs AI generated? Dr. Rashad Richie, who
hosts Indisputable on The Young Turks, has three PhDs and invented
a device that cures Alzheimer's. Why does he have an award from
a website that advertises itself as having an award with AI generated
photos of people holding the award? Why don't the number of new
subscribers on the separate join pages sync up? Why do they have
a Substack when the owner is extremely right-wing? Why is there
nothing to indicate on the main website that The Young Turks
has an advertising department that's operated by Jenk's former
presidential campaign manager who runs a PAC that paid for two
of the advertisements, according to the descriptions on the YouTube
videos and FEC disclosures. Why did Jenk accept sponsorship from
a coffee company that promised to donate to progressive causes
that happen to all be operated, affiliated with, or owned by
Jenk? Why does that coffee site list about $22,000 raised for
those causes, but only a little less than 10% of that can be
accounted for in FEC disclosures? Why does it look like that
coffee site stopped updating in 2022 with no announcement based
on complaints on the TYT forum? Why are The Young Turks sponsored
by Jenk?
Dude, I bet you Berna would lose involved. I bet you. Something
run incompetently? Oh, it's got to be a Berna would operation.
Doctor, a Medicare assistance program that was founded by Vivek
Ramaswamy. Why did they accept sponsorship by Polymarket which
got a large investment from Peter Thiel? Why did Jenk have such
an extended relationship with Joseph Sandberg, former CEO of
Aspiration Bank, before the bank declared bankruptcy and Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I want to make sure does this guy think you can accept money
from people without strings attached and have that money
not mean anything? Is he one of those Cuz like these things would
be concerning for me possibly.
The Polymarket thing is a little different cuz Peter Thiel is
only one of the owners. I don't really think that's necessarily
taking money from Peter Thiel in the same way. I kind of disagree
with that.
And Sandberg pled guilty to wire fraud this past August. Why
did Jenk run for president and raise almost $500,000 despite
being constitutionally ineligible? I nearly lost my mind trying
to answer most of these questions. If there's anyone out there
watching this who can in some form shed any light on this, please,
my sanity is fading. I need to know what's going on.
Day four is the last we'll see of Jenk, unfortunately, and for
a few days following that, The Young Turks had substitute hosts
for their main show. So, we're just going to skip all that and
jump to the next appearance of Ana, which, fortunately or unfortunately,
depending on your perspective, is the show following up Jillian
Michaels' departure from Her Take. >> Man, it is good to
be back. Oh, sh It really, really is. This is my home. This is
where I Hold on. Hello. Then beat. Evil Morty JRX, thank you
for the gifted sub. >> Love to share the news. >> So,
Jillian Michaels walked off the set of Her Take. I don't want
to mischaracterize Ana here, so I will say that she is very insistent
that Charlie Kirk was not by Israel. I do not believe that there
is any evidence
drawing a direct connection between Charlie Kirk's assassination
in Israel. And that the issue she was trying to discuss was Zionist
donor pressure on Charlie Kirk due to his criticism of Israel.
I'm glad she explicitly calls out Kirk getting by Israel as a
baseless conspiracy theory. Her chat doesn't believe her. I'd
like to specifically call out that by minute 30, I had seen four
spam comments literally about the protocols of the elders of
Zion, an anti-Semitic conspiracy theory about
Yes, I you know what I think? I think total schizos typing in
your YouTube chat without you modding them immediately, or I
guess not modding them at all. This definitely proves that you're
an anti-Semitic channel. Definitely, there aren't just schizos
who will go around and spam like anti-Semitic all over the place,
regardless of channel alignment. That definitely doesn't happen
on YouTube. Nope. No way. >> by the world that we're left
unmoderated. He felt that he was being smeared as an anti-Semite,
which he clearly wasn't. And donors, they have a lot of explaining
to do, a lot of decoupling to do. Because donors have been the
number one funding mechanism of radical open border neoliberal
quasi-Marxist policies,
cultural institutions, and nonprofits. This is a beast created
by secular
And now it's coming for and they're like, "What on earth happened?"
And it's not just the colleges, it's the nonprofits, it's the
movies, it's Hollywood, it's all of it. This is not about as
I've said a billion times before. There is also an intentional
conflation of Israel and people in general. And that's done intentionally
to smear anyone who dares to be critical of Israel as an anti-Semite.
Today it was reported that, and this is by Max Blumenthal, by
the way, he's naming names. You're using Max Blumenthal, Russian
Times, Sputnik, Max Blumenthal, the Israeli army actually all
those civilians, Max Blumenthal as a source
Max Blumenthal, the Israeli army
The original report describes the atrocities committed for hours
at Be'eri. This is Kibbutz Be'eri.
Including executions of civilians at point-blank range. Blumenthal
ignores everything that doesn't fit his narrative.
Yeah. Max Blumenthal can be pretty questionable. I think we read
his stuff like with a pretty critical eye.
It's like, "Hey, you're claiming all these things."
I think I was like reading it. I'm like, "Okay, I guess like
I hope you got evidence for all the things you're >> actually
all those civilians, Max Blumenthal as a source here. >> Ultra-Zionist
billionaire Robert Shillman, I kid you not, that is his name.
Always with the names. From there we Uh dude, I did not know
TYT was uh I don't know TYT was probably like this
That's some that's some schlemobile tears right there. >> unintentionally
hilarious segue into the next story. We'll get to the news. We'll
get to the the really important matters of the day.
Um including
Trump basically uh listing people he doesn't like as terrorists
in country. We'll be right back. >> So, Trump has decided
to label Antifa a terrorist organization despite it not having
any kind of structural organizing behind it. >> So, this
really does remind me of the excesses we saw from the federal
government in the aftermath of 9/11. Terrorist attack on US soil,
thousands of innocent Americans died as a result of Al-Qaeda's
attack. And people are scared. And when people are scared, when
people are angry, that's the perfect opportunity for, you know,
the federal government and
figures within the federal government with authoritarian tendencies
to take full advantage. And that's what I believe Trump is doing
here. And here's where you can see the crystallization of why
I called out Ana's unintentional slips on prior days. When she's
trying when she's about to call Trump an authoritarian, she pulls
it back. And in case that might seem like a one-off, she uses
that specific
perfect opportunity for, you know, the federal government and
authoritarian And this is again figures within the federal government
with authoritarian tendencies to take full advantage. And that's
what I believe Trump is doing here. And here's where you can
see the crystallization of why I called out Ana's unintentional
slips on prior days. When she's
Wait, because you wanted to be specific about who she was calling
authoritarian?
I don't think like
I think literally in the wake of like the Charlie Kirk thing,
I sort of understand her given her like whole stick why she would
want to do that. Didn't seem like she was
I don't think she went from like calling I think she's going
to say authoritarian tendencies of the government
and then she was like, "Oh, of certain people in the government."
I don't know. Seems like an irrelevant uh clarification to me,
but whatever. >> She's trying when she's about to call
Trump an authoritarian, she pulls it back. And in case that might
seem like a one-off, she uses that specific phrase "authoritarian
tendencies" to describe other world leaders. And then she equates
it with the hypothetical of being upset at Biden if he cracked
down on protesters, too, by Are the are the other world leaders
like Bibi Netanyahu or saying that people who protested lockdowns
had a right to? Because I remember when, you know, the shutdowns
had happened during COVID. And there were plenty of conservative
protesters
who were peacefully protesting. Despite the fact that, you know,
the lockdowns were under Trump. So, I had no problem with people
protesting shutdowns. And those people were predominantly right-wing.
But the impotency of this specific order does not mean that we
shouldn't be concerned about Trump's decision. You agreed with
Ken Klippenstein yesterday that the National Guard in cities
was kayfabe to distract people on par with Democrats calling
him a dictator. Why would you consider this to be any different?
One tactic has been to target the tax-exempt of nonprofits. I
actually don't have a problem with that, to be honest with you.
I think nonprofits should be investigated far more than they
have been. Not >> I have no idea what Ana thinks 501(c)(3)
organizations are because there are about 1.5 million of them
in this country as of 2022, and giving this administration more
power to go after them is guaranteed to cause I mean, probably
the ones involved in political activity. >> problems because
they're not going to target churches advocating for Trump. They're
going to focus on charities that help people get abortions or
provide housing to LGBT kids when their parents kick them out.
And so, you either believe in our Constitution and you believe
in protecting everyone's rights or you don't. And if you don't
believe in that, then you don't believe in our Constitution,
you don't believe in what this country stands for. So, I guess
we're going to have to wait and see how this really plays out.
Leaders, and this isn't just about America, leaders worldwide
who tend to have authoritarian tendencies, you know, the real
strongmen, tend to have the thinnest skin, don't they? >> You
can just call them authoritarian. So, say it. Say what? Say the
word you want to say. I'm not saying that I want to say it. I'm
just saying that I can't. So, you can't. Say it. Say it right
now.
I will say it with Okay. And you shouldn't allow tragic events
in this country to be exploited by any politicians, any political
leaders for their own agenda and political means. And that's
what's happening right now. For some reason, I'm going to give
Ana some credit here and say that she doesn't mean literally
everything, given how people already politicize things like school
shootings. All right, we got to take a break. When we come back,
we'll talk a little bit about Tucker Carlson's um 9/11 special.
There's this repeated belief Jenk and Ana have that when they
go on conservative media, they're bringing along their ideology
to a new audience that they can hopefully convince. From an honest
perspective, like what the left actually thinks on some of these
issues. But they're not there to be debated. They're brought
on to be a punching bag. Debate on those platforms is not an
effective means of communicating to those audiences. I can't
prove it, but Ana's description of Tucker's 9/11 special reads
like ad copy. Now, I'm going to admit that for the longest time,
when people would say, "Oh, 9/11 was an inside job," I'd like
roll my eyes. Like, "What the hell does that even mean?" And
I don't think that our government
orchestrated 9/11. I don't think that they did something or or
planned to slaughter 3,000 American citizens on September 11th,
2001. Okay? But I encourage you to watch THE ENTIRE
SO, YOU GOT TO GET DO IT. OSAMA BIN LADEN WAS BORN IN RIYADH,
Saudi Arabia to a wealthy and well-connected family. Osama left
his education in 1979 to fight in Afghanistan against the Soviets.
He formed Al-Qaeda with other veterans of the war after it ended
in 1988. Okay, you'll know you'll know how bought this guy is
depending on how
honest he is about the dancing Israelis,
If he if he doesn't mention them at all,
yeah, I don't know. >> They were extremely religiously
conservative and their goal was to bring about an Islamic caliphate
in the Middle East. After Saudi Arabia rejected bin Laden's help
to fight Iraq during the Gulf War, where they instead accepted
US support, bin Laden declared a jihad on both Saudi Arabia and
the US. He was subsequently expelled from Saudi Arabia and disowned
by his family, eventually setting up a base of operations in
Afghanistan with support of the Taliban. Between 1991 and 2001,
several terrorist attacks against the United States and others.
Notes found in 2011 during the raid that bin Laden outlined his
initial planning of the September 11th attacks. The inspiration
came from a pilot in 1999 who intentionally crashed their plane.
Bin Laden would finance the eventual hijackers coming to America
and receiving flight lessons. While multiple American intelligence
agencies were tracking Al-Qaeda members, including ones that
came to the United States, bureaucratic barriers and interdepartmental
reluctance meant that there was no fully coordinated effort to
handle them. During the 9/11 Commission, this was specifically
brought up and called out. On September 11th, 2001, hijackers
smuggled knives and box cutters through security and boarded
cross-country flights on the East Coast that would be loaded
with fuel. Two planes would be flown into the World Trade Center
and one plane would hit the Pentagon. A fourth, United Flight
93, crashed before it could hit any potential target, the passengers
having fought back against the hijackers. While the fires in
the towers were not hot enough to outright melt the steel structure,
they were able to significantly weaken their integrity. And along
with the physical damage caused by the planes, it was enough
to cause their eventual collapse. They fell straight down because
their buildings, the upper towers that buckled the floors beneath
them, didn't have enough force acting on them from the outside
and the angle of the damage within them could not heave their
massive size to fall at a sharper angle. Professional demolitions,
you see, don't just collapse inwards because of the way that
explosives are planted. Part of the professional expertise is
to make sure that the subsequent rubble isn't blasted outward,
which, if you couldn't tell by the plume of smoke and rubble,
the collapse of the Twin Towers very much did. Building 7, across
the street from the World Trade Center, collapsed because the
building caught fire and burned for hours. Though a passport
from a hijacker was found some blocks from the World Trade Center
and was delivered to the police, it was not found directly on
top of the rubble of Building 7. All you need to do is look at
the references on Wikipedia to know that the information Anna
is talking
Okay, hold on. The passport thing is also weird as [__]
I don't care
How the [__] did a passport from one of these people
end up? Dude, no. No shot.
Okay, no, I I I feel like no shot. No >> Tucker special
has been known for almost 20 years at this point. >> it
was informative. It was backed up by documentation that was provided
by Tucker Carlson. Definitely watch it for yourself. I'm After
By the way, if you follow if you go down the dancing Israelis
like rabbit hole, that doesn't lead to like Israel did 9/11,
just so we're all clear. But it's like it's something people
avoid and think is like super anti-Semitic. And it's like I don't
nobody ever did any work to like kind of debunk the additional
stuff like maybe somebody like Ryan Dawson looked up. >> Anna
talks about Trump's speech at the >> shunned the point
of the UN and even tore into European countries for their and
blames Israel for the refugee crisis in the Middle East and North
Africa. Uh the president of the United States is under the impression
that the US can aid and abet um Israel in this Quick rundown
on dancing Israelis. Uh almost certainly
almost certainly the laundry company was some kind of front for
Mossad. Um at minimum, they were doing like a lot of money laundering.
So, it's like a cash-based business
had I I at least one or two of the people who were in the van,
the dancing is the van at the dancing Israelis, at least one
or two of them was Mossad or was like a former intelligence officers.
They were following apparently this moving group actually moved
one of the hijackers. I think they helped him move or they gave
him rides from Florida down up to New York.
Like they were definitely following these people and I think
they were following them as a part of I I'm just giving you like
my recollection off the top of my head. And I think they were
following them for the sake of like intelligence of observations,
probably because they were like citizens like uh let's say Saudi
Arabian or like they were nationals of countries that they were
probably
um without knowing what the full scope of the plan was that they
they didn't know that 9/11 was being planned. They just knew,
"Hey, we're we're tailing these people because we think they're
important like people to understand their movements. Like we're
trying to understand some of these terror cells, what this group's
doing. It's like an anti-Israel group, anti-America group." I
think they they had some suspicion that like they were planning
something,
but uh but like they didn't know 9/11 was the day. I don't I
don't think they knew 9/11 was the day. And then they decided
to celebrate? Um I well, I don't think they knew that the people
they were tailing were the people like I don't know if they kept
tailing I'm guessing you don't keep tailing
um like the same targets with the same people. I'm guessing you
like switch out, right? So, I don't even know if they were still
tailing those people.
But I think that I think they were interacting with those people
in a way that makes it unlikely
that they were just random people.
But I don't think there's any evidence that Israel really knew
9/11 was going to happen at all. Yeah, they did get pulled over.
So, they they danced um they got spotted dancing while looking
over at the towers going down or whatever and somebody reported
them. They got pulled over. Uh they got questioned and then they
got let go. And I think they literally got reported on some news
network as spies. Like unironically, they were reported as
And they probably at least one of them
But they they were eventually let go. I think I
it's kind of one of those things where they were like, "Ah, we
know these people are planning something, but they didn't know
what." And they were tailing them, but they weren't like tailing
them knowing what the actual um when anything
was going on with the plans. They just didn't know. Why are the
Israelis happy 9/11 happened if they didn't do it? Uh because
because a terrorist attack on America from anywhere basically
is going to be good for them. Like all of the countries that
were doing terrorist attacks at that point in time, I feel like
we're in the same place. They said what what they said was they
believed Palestinians did it. Cuz Palestinians hijack planes.
I don't know. I don't know exactly, but I don't
I don't think they would have let that
um in that way. I just just I I just don't believe it.
Um also,
one of the big parts of the conspiracy is they all had flights
leaving the next
Like they all had flights leaving to different places around
the world the next day.
Um and then the owner of the laundry company that they all worked
for or a couple of them worked for disappeared, fled to Israel.
Now, the funny thing is is that guy that guy fled to Israel
and then he moved back to the states like 8 years later. Just
really conveniently as the statute of limitations for for like
money laundering or fraud ran out. So, I think he was probably
laundering money through his business and he left to Israel and
then he came back once the fraud stuff ran out. So, I I don't
think there's like a statute of limitations on
uh questioning. So, if they were like actually concerned about
that, I'm sure they could have questioned him. I just I assume
that like they they got contacts from Mossad, figured out what
was going on and were like, "Oh, well, what can you do?"
They wouldn't let it happen knowingly if for no other reason
that it would be suicide to sign off on that if it ever got leaked.
Yeah, I I feel like that as well. Like basically, if that ever
got let out at all,
uh you would be totally hooped. And like those guys didn't get
killed or anything, the guys who were like dancing there. It's
not like those guys
So, you'd have to assume that they I don't know, never told anybody
about them knowing that the the jet was going to crash in there.
>> stabilizing Muslim and Arab countries in the Middle
East and in Africa and then essentially um lead to a massive
refugee crisis, which ends up getting absorbed by Europe and
then we go ahead and we mock Europe about it. Again, even when
Trump got his first ceasefire deal and there was supposed to
be multiple phases Trump did not get that ceasefire deal. Trump
was not in office. It would have been illegal for them to negotiate
with him. It would have been the equivalent of Reagan saying
that Iran should hold onto the hostages so that he could win
the election against Carter. That peace deal was one of Biden's
last acts as president and everybody on the far left gave Trump
credit for it. But the US is fully captured by the Israeli government.
They're trying to get the Lebanese government to disarm Hezbollah
and in the meantime they're occupying Southern Lebanon and I
mean they just
four American citizens in Lebanon. That was a story that broke
yesterday. It got no attention. You know, there were some publications
that wrote about it. Four American citizens, three of them were
And you want I want to be very clear, Israel, meaning the Israeli
government, not the people, because the people have been protesting.
They they do care about the hostages. The government of Israel
doesn't care about the hostages. And I find it hard to believe
that there's still 20
being there to document the events of the day and how did they
know something was going to happen? Um well, I think they were
there. I don't think they knew something was going to happen.
I just I don't think so.
Yeah, I I just I really don't think so. I think they had weird
weird weird
They said it in an interview. Wait, they said hold on. They said
they knew something was going to happen. They said they knew
there was going to be a terrorist attack that day in an interview.
Really? living Israeli hostages in Gaza. Don't pretend like this
is about the hostages. Israel has bombed several other countries
that have nothing to do with their annexing the West Bank has
nothing to do with It's just lies. It's giving like from PA at
this point. The founding charter for the Likud party specifically
like it specifies that the goal Oh, charter v charter? Hey, if
you're going to say Hamas is a by their charter a genocidal organization,
wouldn't that mean that Likud is also a genocidal organization
if they need to overtake all of those places? I mean, not probably
not genocidal would be the wrong word, but
some bad hombres, all right? Some bad bad hombres. for the party
is to pursue the greater Israel project. And all of those surrounding
Arab countries with governments that are essentially
deferential to Israel at the moment, I mean, Israel's been bombing
your country, too. You're going to sit there and take it. It's
amazing. But Lebanon, go ahead and disarm Hezbollah. See how
that works out for you. I'm sure Israel will play nice. So, are
you going
Hezbollah was founded in 1982 after the Uh Hezbollah is completely
I don't know why she's like, "Oh, yeah, see what happens when
you do disarm Hezbollah." Hezbollah is like
It's just completely Okay.
Uh this guy's going to go, "Um actually, I hope you know that
um I hope you know
Iran is going to totally fund this Shia militia group called
Hezbollah and they're going to do terrorist attacks on Israel
cuz they suck." Israeli invasion of Lebanon. They had a strong
affinity for the Iranian revolution and Islamic governance. With
the support of the IRGC, Iran's army, they received training
and unified to different factions in Lebanon, eventually outlining
their mission as the destruction of Israel, kicking the US out
of the Middle East and establishing an Islamic caliphate. They
commit several terrorist attacks across the world, bombings,
hijackings, and assassinations. After the end of the Lebanese
Civil War, Hezbollah shifts towards becoming a political organization.
In 1992, members run for public office and win. Hezbollah receives
funding and weapons from Iran for their opposition to Israel
and their control of Southern Lebanon splits the country. In
2006, Hezbollah engages in skirmishes with the IDF in order to
take hostages they can exchange for Lebanese prisoners in Israel.
Israel responds by invading Lebanon for the third time. In 2009,
the United States determines Hezbollah is connected to global
drug trafficking. In 2012, Hezbollah joins the Syrian Civil War
on the side of Bashar al-Assad, during which time over
Oh, this was like
I've heard this is what led to like,
this kind of led to the fall of Syria as quickly as it did, that
Hezbollah were some of the most hard-bitten, trained fighters
that were on the side of the Syrian regime. And as soon as they
got
uh it was just like totally ballgame for Syria. Like they had
no other like their own militia, very, very small. Um everybody
else was sort of like like uh what would you call them?
Like clans that they would kind of hire on and have do their
bidding, and those people's loyalty could be swapped whenever.
dozen people are killed, including with starvation and chemical
weapons. On October 8th,
Hezbollah is one of the only coordinated groups that was like
really that were trained, coordinated, and had any amount of
technology that they could use to support the Syrian government.
Everybody else is just like
kind of totally disorganized militia. Hezbollah follows the October
7th attacks with rocket fire and artillery shelling in northern
Israel. Tens of thousands are forced to evacuate for months due
to the continuous barrage. Israel eventually responds with a
fourth invasion of Lebanon preceded by multiple attacks, including
the activation of explosives hidden in the pages of thousands
of Hezbollah militants and air strikes that Hezbollah's leader
at the time, Hassan Nasrallah. Though the pater attack only resulted
in a small number of civilian casualties, the air strikes killed
hundreds. Syrians, upon hearing about the death of Nasrallah,
celebrated in the streets. By November 2024, a ceasefire is outlined
and the Lebanese army, along with the UN and Israeli intelligence,
embarks on the full disarmament of Hezbollah. Israel does not
meet goals outlined for IDF withdrawal in the coming months.
However, the land they occupy is not annexed. But I obviously
fully agree with you. I don't think there's any indication that
Israel assassinated Charlie Kirk. You can't be throwing out theories
like that because it just makes anyone who is legitimately critical
of Israel, and they have receipts to back it up, sound like they're
part of like a cookie group of conspiracy theorists. And in this
case, Then we're on to Congressman Josh Gottheimer appearing
on CNN to criticize Zohran Mamdani and concludes the truth behind
the criticism is that Mamdani doesn't support Israel. Okay, the
fact that he is not willing to be def- Uh that's just factually
correct. That is where all of the criticism for Mamdani comes
from. That's literally all of the criticism of Mamdani. All right,
it's just it's just the Israel thing. Greater Israel thing I
thought was a Fuentes type conspiracy.
No, it's literally something that Likud wants. Absolutely it
is. When they say, "We want to take over Judea and Samaria,"
that is greater Israel. That is a part of the greater Israel
project, and they will not stop saying it. It's not a it's not
a conspiracy. They want that. They very much want that. >> tial
to the needs and wants of a foreign government is the issue.
Then she says that him and anyone else who has accepted donations
from Israel are captured. effectively bribed by the Israel lobby
are captured by that foreign government. Josh Gottheimer happens
to be one of them. And Anna takes the time to misunderstand why
people have a problem with globalize the intifada. It doesn't
automatically mean that you're looking to engage in violent political
action. Again, the second intifada saw over a hundred bombings
of targets like cafes and buses. Before we get to any of What
is uh Well, what does inta- intifada mean? What does it mean?
The term intifada is an Arabic word meaning uprising or shaking
off.
Globalize the uprising? I mean,
These people getting killed all over the place. I kind of don't
blame them for the violent rhetoric. >> the other violence
that occurred.
It's a little bit unfair, uh I think to the Spanish people who
came up with that cuisine. I don't Infatada's infatada's is But
that's the last story.
Sometimes they end on a big dramatic swing. Sometimes they just
kind of came out, and I hate that it's become normalized so that
we don't even cover it that much. So I'm trying to fix that.
One is about Al Green, but he did a town hall recently where
he played uh some recordings of uh people who'd called in who
when we cover these issues, the right wing says, "Oh, you're
bringing up No, I'm pretty sure that those callers were bringing
up race. We're supposed to brush that off, I guess, but why?
And so it it's easy for you sitting at home, no matter who you
are and where you are on the political spectrum, to say, "Ah,
Al Green shouldn't sweat it when they talk about lynching him."
But you might have a different perspective if you were Al Green.
>> It's not like there hasn't been violence. I feel like
I feel like Al Green can be mad about that. Al Green can be mad
about that. >> by right-wingers, including recently. You
say that's just anecdotal. First of all, anecdotal to you, again,
a little bit more concern if you're Al Green. When you ask Republicans,
uh do you believe Obama was born in the US? You know, Bernie
Sanders said this in the past, a great point. His father's from
uh Poland originally, but nobody ever questions uh whether uh
Bernie Sanders was born in the US. And there's Bernie Sanders,
Obama, both uh progressives. In Obama's case, kind of. 39% of
Republicans, even after Trump, admitted that he was lying about
it. So uh unfortunately it affects a huge percentage of the Republican
Party. And then the most extreme elements are the ones here talking
about lynching and murdering black people. It's also Republican
uh politicians. So there's a Republican member of the Mississippi
House of Representatives, his name is Karl Oliver. If uh if the
and I use the term extremely loosely, quote leadership of Loui-
Louisiana wishes to in the an- fashion, ironic, burn books or
destroy historical monuments of our our history, they should
be, and this is capitalized, lynched. It is a trend worth noting.
Doesn't mean that every Republican believes it. It certainly
doesn't mean every Republican politician believes it. But there
are some conservatives out there now openly talking about lynching
black people. And so we should not normalize that. We should
not accept it. We should call it out for what it is. So call
it what it is, and understand what we're dealing with here.
Marshall McLuhan was a media theorist to coin the phrase, "The
medium is the message." What this means is that the way you convey
a message determines how that message is received and contextualizes
it beyond the words themselves. For example, whether a popular
streamer is charismatic or interesting, their popularity conveys
a message of importance that compels people to continue listening
to them, even as they're waiting, potentially for hours, to hear
something entertaining or informative. Their reputation creates
an expectation for an eventual result. A handwritten letter you
receive in the mail will hold greater sentimentality than a text
message. Imagine two people in the '60s spending all night feeding
quarters into a payphone so they can just talk to each other
about nothing. The difficulty, sincerity, and appreciation represented
See the Nick and Dave interview? I saw part of it. I I heard
it was pretty boring, just a glaze past. Honestly, uh
Nick Nick kind of sucks on the make friends everywhere arc. Like
he's still entertaining, but like he's just he he's not funny,
okay? Being racist, being like openly racist, is sort of a cheat
code to be funny, like being transgressive,
but it's uh
like you can't be wide or mainstream popular doing it. So like
it was funny to watch for a while, and obviously most people
think like those messages are terrible. They don't really agree
with them, but they think it's like transgressive and funny.
And he's kind of just stopped doing it. So like the funniness
is not quite the
that the tools we use to communicate determine the value of the
communication as much as the communication itself. By presenting
as progressives, the Young Turks can say whatever they want,
even if it contradicts the principles and standards of those
belief systems, and it will be taken as adhering to them because
the baseline of the communication is that what you are receiving
should be progressivism. As their audience loses the communication
skills necessary to espouse their political beliefs,
On a scale of 1 to 10, how gay was the Red Scare episode? Uh
we Look how far we got in. We got 11 minutes out of 2 hours and
35 minutes in.
listen, if you want to hear people try to produce sounds from
their vocal cords with the minimum required force of air,
Then you want to listen to Dasha and Anna do their podcast together,
okay?
It's just it's it starts to grate after a while, okay? Frankly,
it's just very grating. The resulting cognitive dissonance makes
it so the shortest path to resolving their own belief system
becomes the removal of barriers to implementing it, rather than
doing the work to convince people. There's something I call the
theory of doom spiral that I've alluded to in my previous videos.
When your strongest ideological belief becomes the complete removal
of externalities or consequences, the inevitable conclusion is
that any action you choose to take is an immoral one. There are
two paths that diverge from this perspective. One is to lock
yourself in a room and choose to do nothing so that you can affect
nothing. The other is to make it so no one else's choices can
have the negative externalities you want to prevent. In short,
totalitarianism. Not just the kind you might want to implement
from this perspective, but the kind you start to see in the way
that your beliefs are no longer represented in the way the world
functions. We have lost our democracy. As you see one negative
externality after another affecting people in ways that seem
obvious
I will say, okay,
this video is like infinitely better than the previous than the
Hassan one, all right? It's funny because
it's way better if I feel like it's way better researched.
It feels way better. It's still got like a lot of points I disagree
with, but at least like some of his own commentary is stuff I
don't like disagree with anywhere near as hard, and it's like
not awful.
It's like it's not related, but it's not awful. I don't know,
this guy this guy's doing like a way better video here, and he's
not going to be rewarded for it. >> sleep preventable,
depending on how
I I still Yeah, I still feel like it's kind of gay to go after
these specific >> You pay attention to this stuff, it might
seem out of pocket for me to say that the connection between
the opposite ends of the political horseshoe is anti-Semitic
conspiracy theories, especially when Cenk and Tucker have directly
said, "It's the Jews." But what are Oh, I do definitely hate
the fact that all of his anti-Zionist all of the anti-Zionist
points people make are just automatically assumed anti-Semitic
by this guy. Like literally, if you think Israel has too much
influence, or if you think Israel lies as a government to cover
some of their actions, you're anti-Semitic. You're an anti-Semitic
conspiracy theorist. I don't like that. I don't think that's
>> the conspiracies they actually traffic in. Israel controls
the government. The people in charge are ignoring you. The government
doesn't work. None of your representatives represent you. And
we see what that kind of thinking has done to people. The black
pill isn't nihilism, it's burnout. Burnout people on the fringes
are more likely to experience from the aggressiveness of their
allies, the success of and the high bar for success set by people
like Hassan and Mike and Cenk and Anna. I don't know. Cenk has
been using the same script for the last 20 years. Both parties
are corrupt, the rich control everything, and voting doesn't
do anything until it does. Yes, the Republicans Both parties
are corrupt. >> of August thumbnails in his right. Like
I don't know if you've noticed this, but like he's used multiple
Destiny thumbnails in his show. It's very >> control everything,
and voting doesn't do anything until it does. Yes, the Republicans
are dirty and corrupt as it gets, but so are the Democrats. But
now he's come up against the wall because what everyone else
already figured out is that this time it's real. See that? I
just shot my foot.
And it's real! Jenk cried wolf pack too many times and now the
flock is being
Jenk cried wolf pack >> Our democracy
He really loves The Hangover, okay? >> danger. The people
in charge aren't listening and it turns out it wasn't both sides
doing it. It was just one. No, no, no. He has no intention of
changing a damn thing. For the last 30-plus years at this point,
a lot of people have been able to live comfortable lives on the
aesthetic of rebellion that you could tune in and tune out of
without having to deal with any direct consequences. Media has
allowed us to outsource our responsibility to stay informed and
alternative media has outsourced the burden of maintaining social
cohesion, but now those burdens are Um I think this guy might
have Listen,
I In the Hasan video, I saw basically nothing of value in this
guy. I thought he was going to totally fail. I thought it was
like over for this guy
There's like something here that's closer to
like a possibility.
Um This This one was rough. This one was really rough. I didn't
like it. I thought it was dog [__] This one is better.
It's way better than the previous one. So So I've gotten much
heavier and the people who need help moving them The bar was
not high. And I'm not a fan of like his
total adherence to pro-Israel narratives, but I've gotten a lot
Talking about Republicans and Democrats as the same when Republicans
are out of power is a much different experience from when the
Republicans are in power. Suddenly you remember the years of
the Democratic administration as significantly more stable. You
look like you had a bad day. Hey, tell me about it. You came
in here looking like crap and you haven't said very much. Say
that again. Well, you came in here looking like crap and you
haven't said very much. Hey, tell me about it. Well, you came
in here looking Okay. All right, there's like 5 minutes 4 minutes
left, but I I've got to go. I'm I'm so tired now. Uh thank you
everybody for being here tonight. Um I'm going to put the link
in chat for the rest of the video if you want to watch this last
5 minutes, okay? I'll pin it up there. You guys can watch the
last 5 minutes if you like.
And I'm going to go to bed and thank you to Marty Epstein. Big
shout-outs to Marty Epstein funding the long stream. Thank you.
Thank you, Marty. Really appreciate it, buddy.
Really appreciate it. You know Casino's still live? Probably
rate those guys if they're They're gone. They gone.
All right, have a good night, everybody.
We'll talk to y'all later.
See you.